That's the new noise. Pink
Pang pain. Hello everybody.
This episode of the podcast is
brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace is the all in one platform
that allows you to create your own
professional looking website.
I say professional looking like because
if it's like a, like a fake Rolex,
but now it'd be like a
professional website.
Squarespace is an amazing invention and
what they did is they figured out how to
code a website that allows you to make
your own websites in a very simple,
easy drag and drop fashion.
It is so intuitive,
so easy to use and it works
on absolutely every platform,
which is beautiful.
It would work on an android phone.
It'll work on a windows
computer to work on a Mac. Very,
very easy to use and you
can start your own website.
It's simple as attaching pictures to an
email or to a Microsoft word document.
It's really that easy. Uh, they
also have a beautiful logo creator.
You can create a clean and simple
logo designed for yourself in minutes.
If you're thinking about starting up a
business and you want a website to do it,
Squarespace is your answer.
You're all in one platform.
You can start your own online
business through Squarespace.
They have an online store.
You could set up so easy and quickly.
You can sell digital downloads if you
are a musician or a comedian or you just
want to see if people will pay to hear
you talk, I guess you never know. Fuck it,
man. Just fucking Squarespace
for everything. And there's,
I mean the second model
of the kickstarters,
people that like some dude
made a Kickstarter to make
potato salad and made like
50 grand.
So if you want to sell yourself talk,
and I bet you could probably do it.
Um,
every design automatically includes a
unique mobile experience as well that it
matches the overall style of
your websites or your content.
Will a great on every device for a free
trial and 10% off your first purchase,
go to squarespace.com and enter
in the code word Joe Squarespace.
A better web starts with your website.
That's what they make you say.
That's not my words. My words are
Squarespace is fucking awesome.
It's really excellent. I
really, really enjoy it. Um,
I love the fact that a lot of my
friends use it. Uh, Kara, Santa Maria,
he'll be on soon. She used it to create
her website and manage all her shit. Um,
it's just a really excellent way and,
uh, it's, it's, this is a sign of the,
the new age of technology that
we're in right now that you can,
you can do this so much easier
than it was just a few years ago.
So squarespace.com, forward slash
or entering the code word Joe,
squarespace.com,
enter in the code word Joe and get 10%
off your first purchase@squarespace.com.
And the code word is Joe.
We're also brought to you by blue apron.
Blue Apron is a, a new podcast
sponsor that I really enjoy and I,
I've been using it lately.
I had, um, what it is,
is they send you all the ingredients and,
um,
detailed a photographic instructions
of how to cook them for healthy meals.
And, uh, I just had amine, these peppers,
he stuffed peppers the other day,
like be stuffed peppers.
It was really good. Um,
it's really delicious stuff
and it's super healthy. 500,
700 calories per serving and you would
really imagine that it'd be more than
that, uh, because it tastes really
good. It tastes like, like, Ooh,
it's probably can't be good for you. But
they're designed, uh, by, uh, by chefs,
nutritionists and it's a really,
really yummy stuff. Nine 99 per meal,
they'll send you the ingredients in
the exact right proportions with simple
recipe instructions right to your
door. You know, for a lot of folks,
ordering out is expensive and
it can get pretty unhealthy. Um,
shipping and cooking can be tough too.
Or shopping rather shopping and cooking.
It's like if you get a recipe book and
you want to go out and buy all the stuff
and it, you got to look around
and you gotta like measure shit.
Blue Apron takes care of
all that stuff and uh,
they work around your schedule
and your dietary preferences.
Cooking takes about a half an hour.
Shipping is always free.
And they'll never send you the same
meal twice. Really yummy stuff. Um,
I'll give you a list of some of the stuff
that they have now. Um, this is, uh,
here's, here's one of them. Um,
egg plants with chicken thighs,
cod with Parmesan crusted squash,
spice rubbed pork medallions with peach
salsa. This is not like boring food.
It's really delicious.
Chicken breasts,
Gumbo with chicken sausage and Okra pan
seared scallops with sauteed Sungolds.
Everything you get comes in like
one of those styrofoam containers.
It's packed with dry ice,
so it stays cold for like two days.
Mexican style Turkey Burger. It's not
like they're not bland foods either.
They're, they're really delicious
and a blue pit. Like I said,
a blue apron ships for free to your door.
And if you want to try it out,
see what's on the menu this week and
get your first two meals for free.
Go to blue apron.com/rogan that's the
first two meals free just for going to
blue apron.com/. Rogan I recommend
them. I use them. And like I said,
I cook just a few days ago, I had
this, a delicious stuffed peppers.
It was spicy but not too spicy,
was really good stuff. Uh,
blue apron.com/rogan and last
but finally not least on it.
O n n I t we are a human
optimization website and uh,
we have a, a new product or
a new version of our product,
a t plus a, which is a total
strength plus performance thing.
We just got a new clinical trial results
or we got new clinical trial results in
on t plus on, uh, some, some tests.
It's all available on at.com,
uh, some tests that we did
on a weightlifters, um,
clinical trial for strength based athletes
and all of the information on any of
the supplements, uh, any of the
products that we sell at on it,
we have a research page on every,
if you go to each individual page for
each individual ingredient has a research
page. If you go to it, the research page,
explain to you like for instance
if you got a shroom tech,
shroom tech is a quarter seps mushroom
supplement that's designed to increase
endurance and oxygen utilization.
And you're like,
why the fuck is that about?
Well,
if you go to the shroom tech page,
you will see all of the research along
with references that explains the
mechanisms behind each individual
ingredient, why it works,
how they work synergistically, and what
the studies have been done. And you know,
what, what has been proven about
these individual ingredients? Well,
we're trying to do it on it is
we live in a fantastic time.
And one of the beautiful things about
this time is there's so much information
out there and there were many, many
things that can benefit you physically.
Many things that can benefit you mentally
as far as your cognitive function. Um,
you know,
and there's,
there's a lot of bullshit out there too
and it's hard to figure out what's the
bullshit and, and what's the
real shit well at, on it,
we have isolated what we find to be
all of the most beneficial supplements.
And we sell them to you.
We sell them to you at a very
reasonable rate with great ethics.
If you buy any of the supplements
at on it and you feel like, oh,
it's kind of bullshit. I'm
not really into this. This is,
this is a waste of my money.
We have a 100% money back
guaranteed. First 30 pills,
the order you have 90 days,
you don't have to return the pills.
You just say the stuffed socks,
you get your money back.
All we're trying to do is make
a good relationship with you.
We're trying to create a relationship
where we sell you the best shit you could
possibly get and you feel good about it.
If you don't feel good about it,
that kind of relationship sucks for
everybody. It's negative, it's bad,
it's bad energy. It's not good
for anybody. We're not interested.
We're only interested on selling things
to people that are going to benefit you
and that you're going to feel good
about the relationship that you have.
We sell strength and
conditioning equipment,
everything that you need
for functional strength,
meaning strength that you
can use an athletic endeavors
like kettle bells, steel,
maces, battle ropes. Uh,
we sell medicine balls and ab wheels.
We also have workout DVDs like
the excellent Keith Webber,
extreme kettlebell cardio series, Keith
Weber who will be on the show, uh,
in the next couple of months.
We're working out the details right now,
but I'm a big fan of that guy and it's,
his workouts are insane.
There's so fun to do.
If you're thinking about starting into
any sort of an exercise program, look,
if he's thinking about starting a health
program, just get right on it, you know,
as far as eating healthy
and then mild exercise.
But if you're thinking about doing
anything as far as strenuous physical
activity, I please start off slowly.
It's the most important thing.
The last thing you want to do is try
to exercise and then get injured and be
fucked for six months. He don't want
that to happen. So start off slowly.
Pick a lightweight if you can afford it.
Hire a trainer to show you the,
the, the basic movements in,
in the correct form so that you're not
injuring yourself and start off slow. Um,
if you can't hire a trainer,
there's plenty of DVDs,
plenty of youtube videos online.
You can go and just simple,
basic exercises are broken down. Do
it slowly. Please. Take your time,
build up,
write down your results,
write down your goals and get your shit
together. Son and Gals, gals, daughter.
So I did 10 called girls,
daughter,
a daughter that's just fucking creepy
called dude son. It's okay. Anyway,
go to Onnit. I've talked too
much on and.com O. N. N. I
t. Use the codeword Rogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements.
Relaxed. Ladies and gentlemen, sit down,
grab a cup of coffee.
We're going to discuss society.
We're going to figure out what
the fuck makes this thing tick.
And is there a better way to go about it?
Joe Quirk is here from the seasteading
institute. Young Jamie. Cue The music,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day. Joe Rogan
podcast by night. All Day.
Hello everybody.
Um,
for those of you who are
not familiar with my guests,
Joe Quirk is from the seasteading
institute and the seasteading institute.
Seasteading is a very unique concept
and it's been going around, uh,
over the last x amount of years online.
There've been all these articles and
videos where people have talked about
international waters going
out and creating a city,
a floating city and trying to
reengineer society. This is, you know,
all of the land and the earth has
been sort of claimed and taken.
You can't really start your own cult
in the middle of nowhere without the
government coming in and
crashing your parade.
But can you build a city and design a
utopia based on the mistakes that we see
in society today? Is that a fairly
accurate way of describing seasteading
one of the misperceptions is that
seasteading is not about creating one.
See stead. It's about closest you can get
to this thing. We always have them in.
Yeah. Did you move it around too?
Okay, good. Sorry. We, we can, uh,
we want to create as many steps as
possible to provide people with the
technology to found their
own floating country.
And the key idea is 193
national governments don't
represent the range of ideas
that 7 billion people have produced.
And we're sort of have these government
monopolies that, uh, uh, you know,
control the decisions people make.
And in order to have solutions
for how to live together,
we have to force them through these 193
government monopolies and technology and
every other front is moving forward.
And the thing that's
holding us back isn't it?
We're not innovating in the
technology of governance.
So the key idea is if we can create a
silicon valley of the, see if we can get,
you know,
thousands of Hong Kong's and Singapore's
in aisles of man's on the ocean and
allow innovators to go out there and form
their own societies will discover new
ways of living together and we'll push
forward a evolution in governance.
And what's the stop?
Some fucking psycho like Jamie over here
starting the Jamie country. And, uh,
just having like a one mile square thing
that he's built some raft and it's, uh,
you know, some, he's got some Mad
Max style world. No, nothing, right?
Yeah. Well this is the key idea. I mean,
Jamie can go out there and declare
himself, you know, tyrant of Jamie's dead.
But the problem is he has
to attract people to come
to his see stud and you just
hit on the key idea that makes floating
a nation's different from land based
nations.
I mean,
if you're a some evil dude and you
take control of a land based nation,
you got it. You got monopoly
control over those people.
Those people don't have any choice. That's
the problem with modern governments.
We can't choose among them.
Like we can't among other products that
advanced quickly if we're on the sea,
you got to compete to attract immigrants.
You've got to compete
to attract investment.
You've got to compete to
attract people to uh, uh,
give you money so that you can build
a business in a way that they think is
profitable. Uh, you got to attract
different kinds of ideologues out there.
It's going to start as a business.
I mean,
if you think of countries as being founded
by conquerors and the future ceased
eds being founded by creators,
what I like to call aquaponic sewers,
that sets up a completely
different dynamic.
And if people can choose amongst the studs
that will drive what we think will be
a market of competing governments
competing to police people.
And then this will unleash the
innovation that's out there. Uh,
somebody, you know, for
the past half century,
people have come up with wonderful
ideas for how we could live together.
People have, you can go online and look
up all sorts of interesting rule sets. Uh,
the problem is all ground is claimed and
there's no place we can try this out.
So the, the technology for permanent
floating structures is coming.
Half the earth's surfaces is
unclaimed by existing governments. Uh,
we have a new frontier and I think
it's time we started colonizing it and
building floating cities.
It's a very interesting concept.
Um, but I'm going to be honest,
my own personal feeling about it,
it's not,
not my opinion of how it should go about,
but my own feeling when I hear this,
the idea that I go, yeah,
that would be interesting,
but man,
it brings up all these other problems.
Like some crazy fuckers are going to have
their own weird countries floating out
there and who's going to, what kind of
lawless lands are you going to create?
What kind of weirdness?
But when I think about,
when I analyze my own thoughts about it,
my own instinctive reaction to it,
like it's just the,
I know there's something wrong with
the way society is structured today,
but change brings a whole new set of
problems and people are afraid of change.
Yeah.
Like
to understand,
uh,
seasteading you kind of have to go
deep about where solutions come from.
And so what's the right way to live
together? The answer is we don't know. Uh,
what's the right way to make this
microphone? We don't know. Uh,
these kind of magnificent solutions.
They're not designed by
some really smart person.
They emerge from millions of people
competing in a market to please us.
And so we're on this
exponential, uh, a rocket, uh,
in all areas except governance.
And the problem is,
is that that governments are monopolies
and most of the problems were afraid of,
uh, existing among current
monopolies of governance.
And the key idea is that on the water,
a fluid environment is fundamentally
different from the land based environment.
If you have a chunk of land,
it's,
it's very easy for a conquered take it
and declare monopoly control and then the
government doesn't advance.
It just,
it has no incentive to advance
if you're on the water.
And countries can only form if people
choose to attach to each other,
there is no land unless you
attract people to come visit you.
If those people aren't
happy with your assisted,
they can detach and move somewhere else.
We'll have a completely
different situation where
instead of citizen's competing
to survive their government's decisions,
governments will be competing
to survive citizens decisions.
So if you're a governor and you're
competing to attract citizens and you go
bankrupt and you're cced,
ed disappears is people detach.
And move fluidly somewhere else,
it'll be much harder for it to
kind of control consolidation.
And then you're not even
thinking about citizens.
You're thinking about customers looking
for the kind of governance they want.
And when you think about it, this
is variation and selection, uh,
variation by governments,
selection by citizens. Uh,
and I started as a science writer and a
novelist. I wrote a lot about evolution.
I thought about why as their
progress in the world, why is there,
why aren't things just chaotic? Uh, how,
how has our brain so sublime in biology
that it can understand these symbols?
And I'm sending to you, why is
this coffee Mug, uh, so available,
so cheap and so plentiful?
It's because of variation and selection,
decentralized variation, selection. Uh,
and when I was exposed to pottery,
Freedman's ideas about evolution,
like in the primal soup of the ocean,
I realized he was right.
We're on a fluid frontier where people
can detach and move about and choose the
societies they want.
You would have variation and selection.
And we unleashed the kind of progress
we see in markets and technologies in
governance. And we think of
governance as a technology.
I think it's really interesting,
this comparison that you made in a recent
video that I watched about cell phones
and the competition that
drives cell phones to innovate,
and the reason why we have
such amazing phones today,
while we have all these apps, while
we have all these incredible cameras,
great battery life,
and it's because there's this incredible
competition in multiple platforms all
across the world. Everyone's
trying to come up with the biggest,
best thing every year,
but in government you have none of this.
You don't have any competition.
It's not a bunch of people competing to
see who could, whose ideas are the best.
It's a very rigid,
strict structure that's in place.
It's been in place for a long time. It's
archaic. It's, it's very, very flawed.
The representative government that
we have in this country today,
when you look at the
influence that they have, the,
and you look at the influences on
them as far corporate interest,
special interest groups, lobbyists,
it's all madness. I mean,
no one in their right mind.
If you had a chance to reengineer society,
no one would look at it and go, perfect.
There's no reason to fuck with this.
This is, this thing is great.
Right? You know, it's a terrible,
terrible system and it's the only
system we have and it, it is the system.
And if you try to change that system,
you're a trader or a psycho or whatever
the fuck you are, an anarchist,
you're a cult member.
WhatW or cult leader, um,
this idea is that this same sort of
competition that has led everything to
innovate to the incredible degree that
it is at today, whether it's computers,
whether it's cars, all the things that
we seen in joy today in our society that,
that, that are at this incredibly high
level. It's because of competition.
And that is the exact thing that
is wrong with our government.
This stagnation is two
party system influenced by
corporations that has the same
mandate, the same ideas, the same tired
rhetoric over and over and over again.
And seasteading you believe offers a
potential opportunity to break that mold.
Yes. And it's about breaking
the mold. And I think, uh,
the future of humanity turns on the pivot
of this problem because everything is
advancing very quickly.
Uh, but governance is not,
and it because it is these monopolies
like you and I don't have to argue about,
you know, which app we're
going to have on our iPhone.
And then we all vote on the APP and then
that we all get one app and we have to
agree on it. And then we have to wait
four years to vote on the next APP.
We're all going to get, no,
we, we apps pull refrigerate,
we all get to choose them.
And, and this drives innovation
in that field. Um, and you know,
governments, you can imagine the
government we're in right now,
there's like 300 million people that
have to fight with each other over these
small little changes.
And then everyone ends up with a
bitter compromise and nobody is happy.
And I've been astonished at how people
pushing forward this blue frontier have
been independently attracted
to the metaphor of apps.
So there's this Dutch guy,
uh, a coon Othias, I'm
pronouncing his name wrong. I
don't know how to speak Dutch,
but, uh, he runs water
studio. Um, and he is,
has already created
what he calls city apps.
So we take shipping containers and
he convinced them into schools.
He converts them into a
water purification units.
He converts them into the
hospitals and he proposes,
he wants to float these things too crappy
coastal governments and park them in
the slums and provide schools and those
kinds of things for children. And the,
the advantage these things
have is that they're moveable.
Suppose the government says, we don't
want that. Well then you can move them,
move it somewhere else. Uh, it,
it's much easier than having to
build a school in those areas.
And he calls this program city apps and
I bet you he's going to be doing this in
the next couple of years.
How far out do you have to be from shore?
Does it vary from to country?
It depends on what we're talking about.
It's,
it varies slightly from country to
country in some cases. Uh, it's 12 miles.
So, for instance, uh,
some cs sitters or are physicians
and biotech entrepreneurs and they're
interested in innovating in this
space of stem cells or in, in biotech,
and feel like the regulations written
in 1970 or holding back innovations
written in 2020 another problem with
monopolies. They can't update their rules.
So we're just stuck with these old rules.
Some of these guys just want to get a
cease dead 12 miles off shore and start
pushing forward. Uh,
stem cells and biotech,
which is personalized medicine
is the future of medicine.
It can change everything. Other people
want to get floating hospitals, um,
offshore, cheaper, better, faster
care, millions of people travel, uh,
uh, you know, to India to get
cheaper, better, faster care from, uh,
you know,
American trained physicians.
Why take a plane all the way across the
world and you can take a ferry just off
shore. But to really be
truly an independent country,
you have to go, uh, about
200 miles off shore, 200
miles. Yeah. Um,
that's a really interesting point
you just brought up about medicine,
about a cheaper,
easier,
faster care or better care.
That's a,
that's a very complex and tricky issue
because a lot of people are worried about
quacks,
a lot of people worried about people that
are not following all the regulations
that had been set by the American Medical
Association and that you would attract
bad people,
bad ideas.
Then.
So thinking about the fluid frontier
requires us to rethink these assumptions
that we bring to this.
So imagine the fluid frontier.
That's what you're calling the ocean.
I got,
I got a million of these little phrases.
I like the blue frontier.
So imagine I'm a quack quirk.
The quack and I go out there and I
start offering some crazy procedure that
causes cancer and kills be enhancement,
but enhancement caulking. Let's do,
um, uh, if, if I start killing people,
I,
I'm in a market,
I don't have a monopoly that the first
see stet that like kill somebody or
causes a disaster. That will
be the end of that. Cease dead.
No one will move there. No. And we'll
go there. No one will invest in it. Uh,
just to take an example,
one of the guys I'm going to feature in
my seasteading book is a doctor Chris
Centeno, and he's innovated in
the realm of stem cells. Uh,
there's people that lost, uh, I'll,
I'll take an example. Jarvis Green.
He's a two time super bowl champ.
He lost cartilage under his kneecap.
Chris Santana was one of the,
he has like a thousand
successful operations where
he basically take stem cells
out of your hip,
reinject them into your joint,
you grow a new cartilage like a baby.
Uh,
Jarvis Green had been forced to retire.
Uh, he took Santana those treatments.
He grew it back as cartilage and he
jumped out of bed and signed with the
Houston Texans. He's had fabulous
success with his procedure. Uh,
after a thousand more than a
thousand successful procedures, uh,
the FDA knock on his door and said,
uh, you can't offer this procedure.
Um, it's now illegal in the United
States, this particular thing.
So he was forced to license his
procedure to the Cayman Islands,
uh, to, uh, to, uh, a
company called schematics.
So now people are flying to the Cayman
Islands to get this procedure done. Um,
so you know,
economists call this regulatory capture.
We have this instinct that if you just
make a monopoly of regulators and put
them in place,
that will protect us.
But what ends up happening is the dominant
industries within that area end up
controlling the regulations are having
undue influence in the regulations well is
process that this guy has to go through
in order to clear this particular
procedure that he hasn't done yet.
Well at, at first he thought he, that he
did and he thought that it was all legit,
but the FDA is unclear about
what its jurisdiction is. They,
they came in and literally declared
that your own stem cells once taken from
your body and process are now drugs.
So they're like, okay, well the,
your stem cells are now drugs.
So now we have jurisdiction.
We're telling you to stop. And
you know, that's absurd. I,
I'm actually quoting from the letter
they sent Centeno your stem cells are now
our drugs.
Wow.
Well,
there's this a process that I've gone
through call Regena keen or you're aware
of this? Um, you've heard of it? I
don't think so. There's a, a doctor, um,
I think his name's Peter Weller from uh,
Germany.
He created this procedure where you
take blood out of a person's body,
he spin it in a centrifuge and apply
heat to it and they heated blood produces
this incredibly potent anti
inflammatory agent and it's the,
it's extracted from the blood.
It's like a yellow serum and injected
directly into areas of inflammation,
joint swelling, things along those lines.
Then that's very similar. Yeah, probably.
And Imagine I can donate
my blood to somebody else,
but now I can't donate my
own stem cells to myself.
Well,
this is does,
what I'm confused is this procedure is
legal in the United States. It's illegal.
It's called off label.
If it wasn't for a while,
they had it in Germany
and the like Coby Bryant,
a lot of these athletes
were flying to July.
The UFC guys flew to Germany
to get this procedure done,
but now it's available in several
different places in America.
I got mine done at this place called
lifespan medicine in Santa Monica. And uh,
it's incredible. I mean, it has an
amazing effect on knees. Amazing effect.
I've had it done on my neck, on
my back. I mean, it's just any,
any areas that were like problem areas,
you can reduce inflammation
in this incredible way,
but it's essentially the same thing. It's
taking your own blood out, making it,
turning into the serum and then
injecting it back into your body.
What's different about what this guy's
doing that it's illegal? Do you know?
Uh, I don't know. I mean,
think of it, what were talking
about as a new innovation?
Uh, people are coming up with new
innovations and the climate among people
innovating in health care and in,
especially with stem cells and
with biotech is one of fear.
Like they don't know what the government
is going to tell them to do because the
rules are unclear. They're very complex
and they keep changing the rules.
And this stifles the innovation we
need. So if you look at, you know,
the psychodramas of our age, it's,
you know, healthcare, it's banking.
It's, you know, the public
environment. It's education, it's war,
it's all the things that
governments micromanage.
And so why aren't these things improving
with all the other things we use that
aren't micromanaged by government?
It's because we don't have an innovation
because the government monopolies
ultimately don't permit them.
If you have a monopoly,
you don't want people to compete with you.
Um,
and we want to provide more
market competition on the
ocean in a place where you
don't have to, you know, aggress
against anyone on the ocean.
Well, there's negatives
against this micromanagement,
but isn't there some benefits like,
like for instance,
the government has been cracking down
on Doctor Oz lately for all these bogus
fat loss claims.
Like this has been all these different
things that he's shield on his show that
her mirror, he calls them literally in his
own words, miracle, fat loss cures. Sure.
And then it turns out they don't reduce
fat at all. They literally do nothing.
And then he's in trouble for that.
That's important, right? I mean,
isn't that what they're worried about
with this stuff that someone can tell you,
hey man,
we're going to take some part of your hip
out and we're going to fix your spinal
Bifida.
We're going to fix your scoliosis,
we going to fix whatever the hell you got.
We're going to inject in India.
And it turns out it's not doing
Jack Shit. Yeah. You know,
there might be some sort of a placebo
effect that some people report.
So you have some conflicting evidence,
but is it an important that there's some
sort of a government regulatory or at
least a board of physicians
who are knowledgeable in
whatever field that approve
or disprove any sort of procedure?
Isn't that important?
I think these kinds of
things are important and,
but it's even more important to hit
restart once in a while. Okay. So if,
if people want to stop,
uh,
you know what you're doing that you
like about the reinjection of the blood.
I've never heard of this. They can
call forth a rule, uh, you know,
written in 1975 that the people that
wrote those rules were not able to predict
this innovation that happened in
2014 or whenever it happened. Right.
And the idea is with a new
blue fluid rules on the ocean,
we have to start again with
a new regulatory structure.
And this happens naturally when there's
competition against, against monopolies.
So in a sense,
you're trying to do what the founding
fathers of the United States did.
They tried to see what's going
wrong in Europe and what,
what they don't like about the, the
system that they were a controlled under.
They leave, they come to America,
establish this new country,
set forth these new rules
and regulations is new ideas.
And then a couple of hundred years
later they turned a dog. Shit. Yeah.
Whenever it's a monopoly and it
ends up turning into deduction,
how do you stop that
from happening on Jamie?
See stead because Jamie looks
like a goddamn dictated to me.
I think you get that guy out there on
the sea. He's got his own little island.
Next thing you know, he's banging all
the women. It's like Waco in the ocean.
Yeah,
and I'm glad you're putting this in the
perspective of the United States because
I think of the United States, it was
a giant life raft where, you know,
tens of millions of people who are misfits
in their home countries came here to
try out their crazy ideas and they
discover new ways of living together that
ended up changing the whole world.
And if they're never been this giant life
raft where people could try something
new right now, we'd be arguing,
you know, which works better,
communism or Mara and Arche,
they'll be the only options that we have.
The United States discovered new things
that people just take for granted. Like,
you know, democracy in women's rights
and things like this. It, it, it,
it happened all over the world.
Now Jamie goes out on the ocean
and starts his own, cease dead.
Uh,
he's not claiming some giant bunch of
land with a bunch of captive citizens that
he can control.
He has to convince people that he sees
dead can make a profit that is cced. Ed.
Can provide blue drops and attract
people out there that his sees Stenvall
survive a competing with other seats,
debts.
And imagine an environment where
citizens at anytime can detach, uh,
from a CSWE dead and float
to a different system.
But can they really? Because if you
have a c stead, say if you ha what's,
let's define a c stent,
because I'm thinking it's a floating city,
but the floating city flooding
cities have condos, condos. You buy,
you're stuck there. You've got a
mortgage. You're not going anywhere.
You're stuck on is floating city.
Jamie goes crazy. He's doing math now.
God dammit, I got a Goddamn condo on this.
Meth heads. See stead. I can't get off.
I owe this money. I'm upside down
on my loan. What am I going to do?
I have a family.
My kids go to school and the sea stud.
Yeah. That's what happens in
land based governments, right?
One way to think about this
is, is the Dutch, you know, uh,
their country is sinking. Uh,
they're building floating homes.
They built a floating pavilion. They're
working on a fallen. Sure, they're,
they're there. They're there.
They've been fighting, uh,
against the water for a hundred
years. Building dams, you know,
little Dutch boy that
plugged the damn finger, uh,
there they're so accustomed to the water
when you go there and suggest we need
to build a floating cities and
they don't think it's crazy. Uh,
and the company we're working
with on our floating city project,
Delta Sync Syn see,
speaks explicitly about,
uh,
the mobility of moving units forming
floating cities and how this will create a
kind of market of competitive
governments that would be peaceful,
that would empower citizens
and disempowered governments
so that governments are
going to be constantly aquatic.
Governments will be hustling to attract
citizens rather than hustling to seize
control of them.
Because the ocean is such a
fundamentally a different medium,
which
human nature can compete now. Have
you ever, I'm sure you have Sydney.
Me. I thought, wait, what about crop?
Like how are you going to
protect citizens from invading,
sees debtors from pirates?
How are we not going to have
like waterworld first of all?
Yeah. Yeah. We get this a lot. And, and,
and one way to think about it is that
there's about a hundred thousand boats on
the sea right now. And
civilization required. Yeah.
Like at this moment riding around
the whole world. I think so. Yeah.
Seems like there'd be more than that criss
crossing and most of them are in docs
and they're dropping stuff off.
And you know,
if it weren't for all this fluid
commerce, the, the, you know, the,
the world economy would collapse.
I thought it was way more than a hundred
thousand votes on the whole planet.
Three quarters water. Yeah. It doesn't
matter. And, uh, if you think about it,
yeah,
all those boats have to have some
form of security. And when you,
when you hear about violence,
you almost always hear about land
based governments involved in violence.
You rarely hear about violence and
crime on ships though it occurs.
So all civilization requires some kind
of security and all these boats have
water propulsor and they
have sound propulsion. They
have, they have armed guards.
I think at this point,
75% of, of, uh, of, um,
container ships have a
armed patrols on board.
And I've written cruise ships,
I've walked around American cities,
cruise ships or the size of skyscrapers,
and they're a lot safer than some
of the American cities I've been in.
So security is really not a problem
if you're going to, uh, you know,
make a new floating nation,
you should have some security.
But if you think about Iceland,
Malta, Bora, Bora, Bora, Barbados,
there's so many islands out there,
defenseless against the big nations
Cayman Islands as an example. Uh,
they have no standing army.
A lot of,
a lot of island nations
have no standing army.
They do business with the big nations.
And the way I put it is, you know,
if you're going to found your see stead,
think like a cleaner fish in
the world of sharks. You know,
China's not invading Hong Kong. The United
States is invading the Cayman Islands.
Uh,
Malaysia hasn't invaded Singapore.
When new island nations provide huge
economic value to the big nations,
they do quite well.
So the idea is that just there'll be,
it'll be some sort of a benefit that
the rest of the countries have, uh,
by these competing governments.
Don't,
but don't you think that they would find
that these competing governments put
pressure on them to sort of
innovate and that they would,
they would want to stifle
that and some sort of way?
Well, we shall see because that's one of
the key ideas. I mean, people little, uh,
understand the power of small island
nations to change the policies of great
nations.
And there are numerous examples of this.
The most obvious one would be Hong Kong.
You know,
Hong Kong gained some level of
independence from China, uh,
was sort of an interesting
hybrid called East meets West.
And it created like wealth in a
very short period of time, uh,
embarrassing China into
changing its policies.
And China has a lot of problems, but by
opening its markets with a, you know,
d din chow pains, open door policy, it's,
it's caused at least a half billion
Chinese to, uh, to escape poverty.
Um,
because of the example set by Hong Kong.
And there examples like
this over and over, um, uh,
Portugal decriminalized drugs,
uh,
scientific American published the
fabulous effects and you know,
that's changing policies and the rest of
the world. I can go on and on with this.
Estonia with the flat tax little island
nations innovate in ways that large,
uh, continental nations, uh, imitate.
And we want to create more of these.
Uh, when we look at like the
African island of Mauritius,
when we look at Hong Kong,
when we look at Singapore,
when we look at the Isle of Man,
all these places have innovated and
effected and been used as, uh, uh,
examples of policies that have
been instituted by larger nations.
Now when it comes to a practical
application of this, well,
how far away do you think we are
from a legitimate see stead nation?
And it depends on how
you define a c stead. Uh,
right now we're working on the floating
city project, which we're getting the,
the Dutch company I mentioned
before, Delta Sync, uh,
created a feasibility study.
So we hope to have a small,
uh,
floating a floating
city with some level of,
uh, independence in a, a host nations
territorial waters, hopefully by 20,
20. If all goes according
to plan six years. Yeah.
And this will be in the territorial,
uh, shallow waters. Right. Okay.
So it'll be under the jurisdiction
of that particular government.
It'll be under the jurisdiction of that
particular government. And we've got, uh,
uh,
you know,
we're closing in on deals with those
governments willing to offer us some level
of independence to see what we can create.
And this is not a radical idea.
I mean,
the special economic zone movement that's
happening across developed nations is
all based on this idea of we'll,
we'll,
we'll create one little space where people
can experiment with new rules because
even we politicians or recognize that
our government is screwed up. Uh,
we'll see what kind of wealth
can be created. I mean,
Hong Kong started a movement that's
happened all across the world where now
we're proposing, let us do a floating
one. We don't need any year land.
Let's see what we can create me,
but we can hire some local people.
So we went to create a
demonstration, cease dead, uh,
that'll attract some attention and
attract more brains to the problem.
And then hopefully we'll be able to
move further out and solve the remaining
engineering challenges of
floating breakwaters and a
large enough see steads to
remain stable on the high seas.
And this is, um, this, this is, uh,
an engineering challenge
that remains to be solved.
But if you think about Shell's prelude is,
um,
larger than the empire state building.
It's a floating oil and
gas facility that'll,
they've built the hall and it
should be on the water by 2017. Um,
it's going to be an international
waters for 25 years. Um,
all the technologies are
sort of closing in on,
on solving the problem of creating
a floating structure on the sea.
And I think the more creative
people we attract to this problem,
I think the quicker we'll solve the
problem and have a floating city,
I think it will happen in the next couple
of decades and it's easier to float
than fly. Uh, we have space
stations floating above us.
We can certainly makes these stations.
It's just the people have been
more sold on the idea of space. Uh,
they haven't been sold on
the idea of floating cities.
This is a pretty radical proposition to
invest a significant amount of your time
and like what, what led you down
this road? Because this is, I mean,
this isn't just like,
hey man,
let's move to Vancouver because the
United States sucks. This is like,
let's start our own thing and let's
do it in it's very radical way.
What, what was it that made you want to,
you know, invest so much of your time? Uh,
being part of Silicon Valley and seeing
that so much innovation comes from
people being able to freely compete
and come up with new innovations,
and all of a sudden,
I'm using instantaneous global telepathy,
which we call Twitter.
I never would have imagined such a
thing could exist 20 years ago. Um,
and I think we radically underestimate
the potential for innovation.
Uh,
and I'm very excited about the future
of technology and I'm in deep despair
about the future of governance.
Uh, and when I saw that,
uh,
mobile nations on the sea that can
disassemble and be reassembled elsewhere
according to the decisions of the
citizens, uh, I realized, wow,
this is a fundamentally different way
in which human nature can compete.
That would be much less about conquering
and killing and much more about
creating value and attracting
people to move there. And you know,
we're living in a world where, you know,
you and I are a member of the global 1%.
You know, the World Bank, uh,
estimated that if you make
34,000 US dollars a year,
you're a part of the global 1%.
Meanwhile,
we have this bottom billion who worked
for less than a dollar 25 a day.
$34,000 a year is a global 1% yes.
That's,
that's what the World Bank estimated.
Another group estimated about 55.
That's unbelievable if shive k yeah.
And it's so it's like Americans have
taken the upper part of the hockey stick
and just chopped off the 1% of that
and start complaining about that.
It's not hilarious. Yeah. So we are,
we are fabulously wealthy with our access
to institutions and there's another
billion people or 800 million depending
on how you look at it and who don't have
access to this. And a
Gallup poll in 2009, uh,
there was 700 million
people who told this poll,
I want to leave my country forever.
Get the hell Outta here
and go somewhere else.
And all the existing nations are acting
as gated communities, locking them out.
This is not counting the people that say,
oh,
I want to go somewhere for a short period
of time, make my money and come back.
And these are all the people.
Like tomorrow I will leave my home.
So there's desperate people
who want to go somewhere. Um,
I think see, steads won't be able
to survive without immigration,
without attracting immigrants.
So a lot of seeds sitters or
are interested in aquaculture,
creating vast, uh, seaweed farms
on the sea, vast algae farms, uh,
to provide the world with food and fuel.
The great thing about algae is that they
grow their own bio mass with a carbon
and nutrients,
both of which are polluting the oceans.
So you could in a sense feed and
fuel the world with greenhouse gas.
If you could ramp up these,
uh,
ocean farms to the scale
needed to feed people,
you'd need to hire millions of
people, uh, to have these farms.
I don't think you and I are
going to go work an algae farm,
but I think people in Yemen or Somalia
or Afghanistan would gladly take a jobs
there.
I mean there's migrant workers are
fleeing their countries and trying to find
better lives everywhere. And I, and I'm,
one of the reasons I'm interested in
seasteading is I think we have the
potential to uplift a significant
proportion of the bottom billion.
If you did develop this,
how would you or would you at all
control immigration to your c Stud?
I mean, how do you, how do
you weed out the undesirable,
how do you keep people that are murderers
and criminals from other countries
that are fleeing jurisdictions
of wherever they're from?
They get in a boat and they show up at
your c stead and just fuck the whole
thing up.
Security. Hopefully like you can
imagine you start a avast algae farm,
you're going to be interested in, in being
safe. And there's, there's already, uh,
numerous,
uh,
security industry's working the oceans
that provide security for all sorts of
ocean going vessels so that,
that industry already exists and it does
a better job than, you know, land based,
uh, cops and military is actually,
um, but if you offer a better jobs,
if you offer a blue jobs to vehicle,
uh, they'll take those jobs.
Um, especially when you consider,
they were talking twice,
the population in the United States
has announced that they're ready to go
somewhere else. Um, there's not,
there's not many places they can go.
And you know, I was talking to
a, uh, a woman from Senegal.
[inaudible] got weighed
and she was telling me, you
know, people from my country,
they a stowaway on boats.
Um, and they, and they,
you know, they die. They drown.
She says there are fish food.
There are people so desperate
to get out of their countries,
they're jumping on boats,
not knowing where they're going to go.
Just get me anywhere,
get me out of this hell hole.
And those people will take
a better opportunities. Um,
just like, you know, I'm
Irish a hundred years ago, uh,
my ancestors were extremely poor. They
took better jobs in the United States,
low paying jobs,
and now they're,
their grandchildren are living lives of
fabulous prosperity and we need to keep
this going. We need more life rafts
out there for the bottom billion.
So would you have any sort of a
filtering system to keep people out?
Would you verify passports
and do background checks
on people before you allow
the man mean?
What's the idea behind that?
It was just going to be open and figure
out how to do it along the way when,
when things go bad. I mean,
what's the, and you've got to,
and one way to think
about this is it's not a,
it's not about designing a society.
I have no ability to design the society.
Uh, I'm working to provide the technology
so that other people can design their
societies,
um,
and the like new countries created
in the past few decades, uh,
apply more modern rules to their founding
and they do better jobs that, you know,
there's been a something like 29
new countries since like 1990.
I hope I'm getting those numbers. Really.
Yeah. There's, there's been like, um,
where are they? They're like 6 cents
a, you know, 2000 to really yeah.
People don't realize new countries are
created all the time and people have to
say that. I've never even heard mostly
countries breaking up into smaller pieces.
Um, and um, are any
promising? Oh yeah, yeah,
yeah. I think, uh, East Donia
is incredibly exciting and it's,
it's innovating in ways larger
countries are not, you know,
they've innovated in the realm of a
flat tax, which was unthinkable. Um,
and I think I counted something like,
since Estonia innovated in
the area of the flat tax,
they grew it like twice the rate of
surrounding European nations causing
arguments among their politicians to,
to, to, uh, instantiate a flat tax.
I kind of like 22 countries that have
adopted, he's Stoney is innovation.
So new countries innovate, old
countries do not. And New Co,
the new startup countries set
the examples that change things.
So why are we waiting
for historical accident?
I'd like to create thousands of these.
So the,
the place where you have to let go of
the desire for control is to realize it's
going to be up to the founders of these
societies how they're going to provide
security.
It's going to be up to the founders
who they're gonna hire and what they're
going to pay them there.
There were not controlling,
we're empowering people to try things.
And the reason I'm less afraid of aquatic
nations than continental nations is
because aquatic nations will have
to attract people to live there.
You're not going out and you're,
you're not conquering some place
where people live and saying,
I'll keep everyone safe.
You're saying I got to provide you
an incentive to come live with me.
And then there'll be other see
steads for the same workers,
for the same innovators,
for the same doctors and lawyers.
If they provide better and cheaper
services than people will detach and move
there.
We're in a situation where there's nothing
stopping the inexhaustible growth of
governments because they
are monopolies and we,
I think humanity has to innovate in this
space and it requires this deep mind
flip to think about the difference
between competing over land and competing
over fluid.
Think of them as houseboats on a,
on a liquid. It's much harder to
seize monopoly control with your,
with your military over
a bunch of boats on the ocean.
Is it though?
I mean it seems like they were just kind
of surround you like if you tried to do
a Waco in the ocean,
it seems that if you had like the
branch Davidian complex out there in the
middle of the ocean,
like I know Jamie's planning,
we'll get that motherfucker look
at him over there. He's planning.
If you decided to do that and build some
city and put up giant barbwire fence
and have sex with everybody, his wife
and the in store a lot of weapons,
the government would probably come
in. I mean, if you say security,
and I'm obviously playing devil's
advocate here, but if you say, uh,
everyone will be responsible for
security and your, she's dead. Well,
at what point does security become an
army? Like, are you allowed to have a jet?
Are you allowed to have nuclear weapons?
Are you allowed to have, you know,
if you innovate to the point where you're,
you're,
you're building some fucking Tesla
weapons out in the middle of the ocean,
they can shoot down anything
that comes anywhere near you.
At what point is the government gonna
feel threatened by you and move in?
How big can you get? I mean, do you,
does every seasteading nation have to be,
um,
sort of either like a
satellite of a larger nation?
You know what I'm saying?
Well, um, conquerors have incentives.
And the way to think about how this
works is to think about precedents that
already exist. Um, so let's see.
It's, is it the islands of, um,
Barbados and Bora Bora that are just a
few miles off the coast of Venezuela,
a independent countries that are much
wealthier and Venezuela doesn't attack
them? Uh, the Cayman Islands, you know,
in many ways takes a spiteful stance
towards the regulatory structure.
The United States welcomes
lots of, you know, uh,
physician mavericks and Financial
Mavericks to their shores.
The United States doesn't
attack the Cayman Islands.
Right. But they're not 200 miles off
shore with nuclear weapons. I'm just, yes,
I'm sort of saying if you just established
a city that became a country that's
floating off shore,
that's heavily armed.
Right.
So you have to ask,
how are a continental nations
in control of nuclear weapons?
Why aren't, uh, island
nations in controlled?
Small island nations don't have nuclear
weapons and most of them don't have
standing armies.
You have to pay for that stuff.
Like for me to go attack
someone and kill someone,
there has to be a financial
incentive for me that I feel like,
or whatever incentives incentive of
power that I feel like the cost of the
invasion is going to pay back and some
great thing I'm going to get like the oil
or the,
or any other natural
resource that might be within that nation.
A small island nations like Hong Kong,
they don't have any natural resources
except a big port and they're able to
create all this wealth through
trade and through policies.
So how does a cease dead get
enough money to get a, um,
to build up a giant nuclear warhead or
something and launch it from the seas?
Couldn't Hong Kong store to do that
with all the money that Hong Kong is
generated whenever they
started building an army?
I think that would probably be a
huge issue. Don't you think if,
and yet they don't because they,
if you own a continental nation,
you like say China,
you have a control over
a captive population,
you can fleece, uh, and
pay for whatever you want.
So you have an amazing amount of capitol,
brain power and money to
build your nuclear weapons.
And this is why these large,
um,
these large governments to me are much
more of a threat to the world and some
floating island that has to, you know,
not go bankrupt as it gets started.
What is the major roadblock as far as
technical capability of creating something
along those lines? I mean, how has,
has the technology been invented in order
to create a safe floating city or is
this completely theoretical?
The key enabling technology at this
point is how do you create something that
can float on the high seas
that is affordable by say,
you know,
the average middle class American and I'm,
am I right also in thinking that you
don't have to worry about waves like uh,
as far as like rogue waves or tidal waves
cause those more effect like land than
they do the actual ocean itself.
Like if you're floating,
you just kind of like Bob up and down
a lot, you wouldn't get swamped. Yeah.
I think you're talking
about tsunamis rogue waves.
Like what was that stupid movie with Mark
Mark. Perfect. Perfect. Starbucks store.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. As, as tsunamis
are harmless on the deep sea,
people are shocked to hear that soon.
Like A,
a tsunami wave can literally be thousands
of miles long. So if you're on a boat,
you know, you, your book,
over the course of a day,
your boat goes up about Demeter and goes
down to meet her and you can easily not
notice it.
Tsunamis become deadly when they hit
land and they start to roll and pitch and
bury a city.
Uh,
there was a report that I really love
where there's scuba divers off the coast
to some, uh, Thailand, uh, city.
Uh, they were underwater, uh,
just swimming around having
a vacation and they say, hey,
there's a weird discoloration in
the water and there's a little,
there's a little undulation
happening. Oh, well.
And they go back to scuba diving
that come back to the surface.
And the hotel where they ate breakfast
in is destroyed. The city is destroyed,
their swimming, they swam through us
and I'm in and didn't notice it. So, uh,
coastal cities are sitting
ducks for tsunamis.
If you're going to be subjected to a
tsunami, you'd be safer. A sea stead.
Huh?
So those big crazy ways from a perfect
storm, like if something comes,
so that, so that is the fundamental
engineering challenge. Huge waves.
On the ocean.
So we have the technology to create a
floating city in shallow territorial
borders. And we're going to
do that soon. Hopefully. Uh,
the engineering challenge to be solved
is how do you create permanent structures
on the water, um, that, that
are, that can stay out there.
Like you can create boats,
but the problem is boats have to come
to shore every decade or two decades to
get cleaned, right? You've got to
have something permanent out there.
And there's numerous technologies
like, um, one that's been in a,
um, commission been in operation
since 1962 was the flip ship.
It's basically shaped like a baseball bat.
You tow it out into the ocean and then
use ballast tanks so that it flips and
then it stands up.
Right?
So say like one sixth of the ship of
this big baseball bat is above the water
and five,
six is below the water and it's described
as being a stable as a fence post.
Uh, and these were on the water in
1962. They're still on the water.
So most of it is under the water.
Most of it doesn't have what he,
essentially the anchor that would be
the route that would be the route.
And so it can sit there among the waves
and you're on this thing or underwater,
you can imagine looking at a
window at a permanent aquarium.
Jamie's got a photo of it that he just
pulled up here. This is what it is.
Yeah. That's what the top
part of it looks like. Oh. Uh,
so most of convincing people of the
potential of [inaudible] stead involves
telling them about what
already exists. I mean, that,
that thing is older than I am.
It's been around. Really? Yeah.
So it's expensive. It's too
expensive for regular people to use.
It's used by the military.
It's used by scientists. Uh,
but you're seasick free on that thing.
Now imagine you make four
of them or three of them.
You can build a platform on it. Uh,
you can build floors below the ocean.
You can build the floors
above the ocean. So, um,
of many of the C's dead designs you can
see on our website are built in such a
way that the, uh, it
looks like they're, uh,
on pillars, on like land in shallow
water, but they're actually not.
If you build your pillars deep enough
and buoyant enough, you can set your,
see stet up, say, you know,
50 feet from the surface of the ocean
and the ocean waves are moving underneath
the sea stead and its remit
remaining relatively stable,
uh,
on these pillars that are just in water.
And the pillars go down much further
than you would normally think.
It's kind of like building
a foundation in a swamp
saw something where they made it so
they figured out a way to make things so
stable that they, you can play
billiards on a, on a boat.
They figured out a way to stabilize
like a pool table to the point where it
reacts instantaneously to the movement
of the ocean and the ship itself where
you can see it stays constantly balanced.
Yeah. There's so much I
can tell you about. I mean,
I wrote on a cruise ship and Alaskan
cruise ship and a month ago I was on a
Galapagos cruise ship and you
can have your Martini glass,
you pour the Martini glass, you set
it on the table. It's not, you know,
it's not rolling over. It's like
the larger you make your C's dead,
the more stable it is in the waves. Those
bolts are kind of see steads, right?
I mean if you really think about it,
well that's the precedent we use is to
get people thinking about cruise ships.
I mean, they're the size
of skyscrapers. I mean,
you can look at pictures on the Internet
and realize those tiny little answer
people and everything people do in cities
they're already doing on cruise ships,
you know, simulated skydiving.
They have rock concerts on them.
Yeah.
Here's this video of these guys playing
pool on a cruise ship and the boat is
moving,
but yet the balls are,
are rolling perfectly because the,
the ship,
if he could see the ship is moving,
but the table stays completely level.
So it adjusts with the,
the movement of the ocean.
The table consistently constantly adjusts
so that the floor may be moving but
the balls are never
rolling and I incredible.
That is incredible.
And that would obviously be on like a
smaller boat where it's not naturally
stable anyway because I've been in cruise
ships where people are playing pool,
you know,
you can't even tell you on the water.
But if you think about the
sinking of that Russian sub,
uh,
you know,
they had to find a company to lift that
thing off the water without causing off
the bottom of the ocean without causing
a disaster. Glo Mar situation, uh,
this was a long time ago.
It was a few years ago,
I think it was called the [inaudible].
And the company is called Memo Matt,
I don't know how to pronounce these
things because they're in different
languages, but they had to lift
this thing centimeter by centimeter.
And they had to do,
they had to create a platform on the
top of the water and create virtually
perfect stability while while they
lifted this thing slowly off the Bot,
you know, a nuclear sub off the bottom
of the, uh, of the, uh, of the ocean, uh,
in order to lift it up. And it was
a tremendous engineering feat. Um,
we can go on and on like this
and we might bore your listeners,
but there are multiple technologies
that are all closing in on, hey,
we can get something permanent on
the sea. And it looks like, um,
Shell is gonna is gonna build one
soon. So the, the question is,
now how do we make it cheaper?
How do we attract more brains to this?
How do we get a kind of x prize,
uh,
attracting people to solve
this engineering challenge?
I think once we solve this challenge,
seasteading will,
will drive itself.
Shell is going to build one and they're
building an oil refinery that floats.
Is that what the want?
Yeah. Uh, and it's not, they're
not calling it a see stead,
but it will be, you know,
200 miles off the coast of Australia.
Uh,
it's built in like South Korea and it's
bigger than the empire state building.
You can fit several football fields on
it and it's going to be in international
waters for up to 25 years. So pretty
much any time a city is it, I mean,
think of it as like a giant,
uh,
I'd like a giant skyscraper on the water.
Will be reasonably self sustaining or is,
is it going to rely on constant visits by,
by freighter ships? Like all
ships in islands, everywhere.
It requires on constant visits
and trade and, but this is like,
they don't think of it as
an independent country.
They think of it as a shell
prelude fling facility.
I'll give the size of that
thing. It's gigantic. Um,
bigger than the empire state
building. Yeah, more massive.
And see if I can remember how many
football fields on it you could play.
I think it's five like
football games in a row.
So it's,
it's doable.
It's just still too expensive.
The shell can afford that and they can,
and they can pay it back. So
our skyscrapers, right. I mean,
you and I can't go out and build a
scotch grabber. Right. But we could,
if we had a great idea for a business
that would work a board of floating
skyscraper, like, like
a gigantic hospital,
um, uh, floating Cayman Islands.
You know, one of my heroes,
uh,
who's building a health city in the
Cayman Islands is named a Debby Shetti.
Uh, he did create name. Yeah. He's a,
he's an Indian guy and he did
amazing stuff with, you know,
he'll offer Americans,
uh,
heart surgery for one 10th the
price with the best doctors,
and that makes them enough money where
he can offer a medical insurance to rural
Indians, uh, for 25 cents a month.
So he plays this kind of
jurisdictional arbitrage.
So now he's moving to the Cayman Islands
and building what are called health
cities ready to catch the wiving,
the rising wave of Americans who are
going to be dissatisfied with their
healthcare and when a faster,
quicker and cheaper and we'll fly there.
And I, I've been looking at him as a
guy that seems like he understands what
seasteading would be.
He seems to understand the principles
and he's applying them by using real
islands.
And I've always fantasized if I could
talk to him and get him to like invest in
a cced dead.
And you know,
I almost peed my pants a few months ago
where he was in the news and he said,
you know, the best place
to have a floating hospital
would be on a ship, you know,
off the coast of a major American city.
Given that we don't have that,
I'm going to build one in the Cayman
Islands. And I'm like, oh my God.
Like there's so many people thinking
along these lines. Like, if we could just,
we have innovations and technologies
moving forward and we have regulatory
structures and government's holding it
back and the world can't be held back.
The world has to move forward.
Well,
you don't want to overthrow
governments that's violent.
You want to innovate and compete with and
embarrass governments the way you know
Singapore and Hong Kong and
the island man have done
well.
And I'm on a small scale.
When you see certain laws
that are in place that are um,
very restrictive and
they don't make sense.
And then you see states that take
chances like Colorado with their medical
marijuana practices or rather a legal
marijuana where they're making untold
amounts of money. Now, I mean
far past what they projected.
And now other countries are starting to
look at the revenue that's being brought
in hundreds of millions of dollars
in tax revenue. And they're saying,
you know what? This is, why would
we avoid this? This is crazy.
Like what are we seeing
as far as violence?
What we're seeing a drop in violent crime?
What are we seeing as far as drunk
driving and driving accidents?
We're seeing record lows,
record lows as far as like traffic
fatalities and drunk driving.
Why aren't you know? That's exactly what
happens. Someone comes along and says,
listen, the laws that are in
place, they don't make any sense.
The the structure that's in
place, it's, it's antiquated,
it's archaic and it doesn't match
up with what we know about medicine,
what we know about physiology, what
we know about life. Let's change it.
So they're changing it and you've seen
the benefits and now all these other
states are now first switching to medical
marijuana and projecting legalized
marijuana all throughout
the entire country. It's the
same sort of a situation.
It's,
it's these archaic,
very restrictive laws that don't make
any sense and there's no competition
because of the monopoly of government.
These laws are in place and people say,
well,
you could vote him out.
Do you know how many much fucking money
is spent keeping those laws in place?
Do you know how many people
lobby the prison guard unions,
pharmaceutical companies,
et Cetera, et cetera.
So many different companies lobbying and
spend millions of dollars of money to
keep the laws in place. If you could
have one state, just one state,
you know, let's say South
Dakota says, you know what,
we're not so happy with
the way things work. Well,
we're going to do is we're going to open
up South Dakota to a complete Utopian
society.
We're going to just start from scratch
instead of seasteading wants to come over
to South Dakota and Char tribe
rebuilding society over here.
Would you be interested in something
like that or do you think the only way to
do this is to do it in the ocean? Uh, I
ran my first podcast last
week and I interviewed, uh,
Zachary because Sarah's who
welcome to the club, you know,
welcome to the pod class clown.
Yeah.
First one is my first one you got in
there and it was a marvelous interview.
He's a fascinating dude and he
founded the startup cities institute.
Now, uh, the special economic zones,
there's actually thousands of them all
over the world is places like India,
South America, China are all like, yeah,
it's embarrassing to be in a
country that's not performing well.
Let's create special little zones
where we can start over with new rules.
And there's, you know, they're called free
cities, they're called free ports. So,
you know, Zach has been, um,
pushing for pushing the F uh,
in Guatemala. The idea of the
Morse free cities, you can create,
the more innovation you can
create, the more, uh, uh,
wealth you can create for poor people if
they choose to move there and take the
jobs. And our whole discussion was,
which is a bigger challenge, the,
the engineering challenge of building
something on the sea or the challenge of
working at a deal with existing
comp, uh, governments and,
and asking them for a piece
of their land. Right. Um,
and some of these places have
been very successful, you know,
Shinzen across the bay from Hong Kong,
given the example that Hong Kong set,
you know,
China agreed to create a little special
economic zone called Shinzen and you
know, creating, once
again, spectacular wealth.
So now they've allowed more of these
experiments. So the way you know,
in industry isn't working as if you
have to argue about it. You know,
in our arguments don't matter.
Our, our experiments matter.
And the reason we have to argue about
politics is because it's not innovating
and everyone is frustrated.
And the more startups
societies we can create, um,
the more we'll empower innovators to come
up with ideas. We haven't thought of.
The best solutions always come
from outside our, our heads.
So I'm a big supporter of startup cities.
Startup cities are people that are a big
supporter of seasteading and you know,
may the best societies when,
hmm.
Um,
but your idea is primarily to build it
in the ocean and if you do build in the
ocean,
what,
what are the potential natural disaster
worries you have to worry about?
If you don't have to worry about waves,
you do have to worry about like things
like hurricanes and things like that.
Right? Would you have to engineer the
building's very specifically to deal with
tropical storms and
things along those lines?
See steads our mobile,
uh, the people that are,
that are sitting ducks in the face of
a hurricane or is anyone that's like
nailed to a,
to a coastal nation and he's cities,
all the mega cities in the world are
springing up along the coast and many of
them are susceptible to hurricanes.
If you're a cease dead, uh, you know,
I grew up in the east coast, I was
subjected to a few hurricanes, you know,
about them a few days before they come
and then it's battened down the hatches,
get in the basement, you know, whatever
you have to do if you're a c stayed,
you could potentially just move
out of the way as boats do.
So you would just, I mean there's some
of them that are just massive though.
I mean there's, there's like Katrina,
I mean, how many states was Katrina?
How many states wide was Katrina
before it hit? It was enormous.
Is enormous. And I'm curious
to know, um, how much,
how much lead time did people
have in the warning of that
you're leading me to talk about,
you know,
I have to get bigger and bigger
with w c sittings a big subject.
And the thing I want to tell you about
now is we'll start with the fact that
hurricanes don't cross the equator.
A lot of people don't know that, uh,
there's never been evidence of a hurricane
crossing the acquaintance south to
north across the other
one. Like going, yeah,
you mean like go along the vertical
access to the equator or go above it,
go above the equator or go below the
equator. Really? Yeah. Why is that a,
I don't know. The coal, the role
is for, I have no idea. But um,
so there's this Guy Patrick Takahashi
who's like a biochemical engineer from
Hawaii and numerous people like that are
pushing forward this technology called
Otec,
e c a and it's basically ocean
thermal energy conversion.
And it basically takes advantage of
the fact that the surface of a tropical
ocean is very warm and a thousand
feet down. It's very cold.
And you get like a huge
temperature differential,
which can drive a gigantic steam engine
and basically use the ocean itself as a
solar panel, uh, to, you know,
power and ocean city or an
ocean plant ship as he calls it.
And also power the land
based nations of the world.
We can completely replace a fossil fuels,
um,
with a clean green renewable energy
of Otec. Does it sound futuristic?
Uh, they built a working one in 1979
during the Carter administration,
uh,
as it was part of the oil crisis.
And then soon after that when oil
prices fell, Otec was abandoned.
No more OTEC plants were built.
Now there's a whole company's
involved with building Otec.
They're going to build one off
the coast of China. Numerous, uh,
island nations have commissioned, um, uh,
OTEC plants to be built off their coasts.
The Bahamas is going to build to,
so why did I go to this?
We're talking about hurricanes
crawling quarter. Yeah.
So the best place to build these
gigantic Otec plants is on the equator.
Cause that's where the surface water
is warm mist. And as an added benefit,
you're safe from hurricanes for the
most part. So the equator itself,
how wide is the equator?
Like what's considered the equator?
I mean it's not a line, right? Yeah, it's,
it's a, it's, it's where the, you know,
the earth spins on its axis and it's
where it's basically the earth that spends
the most time closest to the sun. Uh, uh,
you know, there must be a height though,
right? Yeah, that's a
good question. It's funny,
I was just at the equator when I went to
the Galapagos islands on my little trip
and, uh, I don't think
there's an official width, uh,
of the equator,
you know,
I have no idea or height and it seems
like there should be, yeah, I don't know.
I think it's just the line
where the earth's spends
the most time closest to the
sun. You know, everywhere else we have
seasons because the earth is on a wobble.
It has length, no width or
depth. That makes sense. A line.
It's just a very fine line with no
hide at all. It's an abstraction.
A strange,
so you'd have to like be on that line.
What if you went up too high?
One of like the northern tip of your
sitting at fucked by a hurricane. I mean,
that could happen because a lot of, you
know, a lot of hurricanes are caused by,
you know, very warm water and put some
still bizarre that it would not cross.
Yeah. Like starts, you know,
sort of near the equator and then
it moves either north or South. Wow.
That's so weird. Yeah. And I don't
understand why I'm, I'm just, uh,
it's one of those things I've been taught
by the numerous aquaponic or as I've
spoken to the thing that makes seasteading
that shows that it's a Meta idea is
all the diverse people
that come to seasteading.
What their unique solution that no one
who talked about seasteading is thought
of. Um, you know, on the,
on the website we have this thing called
the eight great moral imperatives of
seasteading and each of them,
it's a little video thing that I made
to try to introduce people to the key
ideas.
Each video is like five minutes long.
And each of them features and Aquaponic,
sure.
That didn't even know
about the other guys.
But here's about seasteading
and comes to us with,
I have an idea for this seaweed farm and
this is how we could lower the carbon
acidity of the ocean and I could do this
on a massive scale and blah, blah, blah,
blah. And then we have
another guy, you know,
one of my favorites is a Neil sims who,
who,
who runs the Velella, uh,
research project. He has, um,
fish cages that a school
with the moving fish.
So he literally see if I
can describe this to you.
Think of the Hawaiian islands
as, um, rocks in a stream.
And as the ocean comes by the islands,
it creates a little eddies
behind these islands,
like little leaf floating around.
So he's got these circular fish cages
where he keeps the fish inside them.
So the fish just kind of
school in a circle and the,
the cages move with the schooling
fish around in a circle and you,
and he has a gps on the cage.
So the fish are out there.
There's no environmental or negligible
unmeasured on measurable environmental
impact. The Fisher on the deep
sea living as if they're wild. Um,
these are crazy ideas
and, but they require, uh,
being out in the place where there is
no government jurisdiction for the most
part.
I mean off the coast of Hawaiian islands,
there is some government
jurisdiction, but we have, you know,
45% of the world's surface
unclaimed by existing, uh,
governments where people are innovating
in these unique ways to feed the world
with sustainable sashimi
on the deep oceans.
Is the idea of managing people just an
archaic idea and is what you're saying,
what you're talking about
when you're talking about
micromanaging the government,
trying to manage all these things and
in fact fucking them up with too many
regulations.
Is it impossible to really regulate human
behavior and it's at a certain point
or to really regulate,
especially when it comes to things
like innovation when it comes to, uh,
I mean is our regulations,
in fact,
roadblocks to innovation,
the creativity of 7 billion
people is unpredictable.
And there's always something new coming,
especially as a c center where people
come to me and tell me about things that
could use seasoning for him.
Like I had no idea,
I can't believe you're telling
me this is very exciting.
So I've had to embrace my humility
that I don't understand what's coming.
So people are afraid,
people want regulations and rather
than take a position on whether we need
regulations or not,
we should all agree that the way to
create sound regulations is not to simply
create a monopoly that has permanent
control over any particular industry and
writes a bunch of rules,
passes a bunch of laws,
accumulating thousands and thousands
of more laws. And you know, those,
those more laws don't keep pace with
Moore's law to make upon, I mean,
we have, uh, thousands,
tens of thousands of regulations written
in the 70s that are still constraining
innovation and those people were not
capable of predicting innovations that
we're going to come in the 21st century.
So if you want regulations,
you need them as organic and dynamic
as the industries they regulate. Right?
But how does that work?
I mean, how does anyone calculate
the sort of regulations to,
especially an incredibly
fluid and dynamic industry,
the technology industry that most people
like say if you're trying to regulate,
you know,
certain aspects of cell phone development.
Most people just are just not
qualified to understand them.
They just don't know what
they're talking about, right?
You're talking about something that's
changing year to year. If you, if you, uh,
made regulations as far as the development
of cell phones back when the Motorola
Startac was state of the art and he tried
to apply those same innovations today
with the Samsung galaxy s
five. I mean, Holy Shit,
you're dealing with a
completely different animal.
One of them is essentially a computer
that could run your whole life and check
your heart rate and do
all kinds of nutty shit.
Locate it's got a gps on it and can
tell you where to go and navigate you.
And the other one was just a
simply a way to call people,
right? And the, the humility. We have
to embrace this. We don't know, right?
We don't know how to regulate
the future. Uh, and so if you,
if you confront the fact there is no
human being that can pre irregulate the
innovations that are
happening in a decade, you,
you realize that the way to solve these
problems is not to simply create a
permanent monopoly that you know,
rights.
What may more way more laws than it,
than it allows to go away.
You need to break up those monopolies.
You need a competing jurisdictions.
If, uh, uh, sort of like a, I
think of it as fluidly overlapping,
uh, um, uh,
a market of developing
regulations on the ocean, uh,
initiated by the industries.
And we see this in lots
of other industries where
regulations develop over time
from within.
A lot of people don't know that a lot of
the things we take for granted, aspirin,
a knee operations, lots of
heart surgeries, they just
came from the ground from,
from, from doctors experimenting. Um,
so every country goes through this cycle.
It's,
it's such a constant cycle that it's
actually a cold. What is it called?
Cardwell's law.
There's like an official name for it
that you start out with these blossoming
industries. Uh, there's some disaster
that happens that causes regulation.
In the case of medicine, it
was the thalidomide scandal
that happened, you know,
decades ago.
So then these regulations come in
place to protect people from disasters.
But by creating a monopoly
of regulation production,
the regulations just accumulate and
accumulate and none of them ever go away.
So you, the, the, uh,
the bureaucracy rides on this wave of
innovation and then it starts dragging it
down because there's just no incentive
for the regulators to cut back on their
regulations and you ended up killing
the goose that lays the golden egg.
But essentially
the balancing act is between
safety and innovation. Right?
That's the balancing act when,
especially when you talk about things
like thalidomide, um, how do you,
how do you sort of manage that?
How do you manage the balancing act of
safety and innovation? Because in the,
in terms of especially some
untested medical procedure,
like I have a friend who, um,
got a stroke from Vioxx was some,
some, uh, arthritis medication.
And you know, I was a young guy.
He got a stroke.
It's pretty crazy.
And they pulled it off the market and
now it's illegal and it was lawsuits and
all this jazz.
But what,
what do you do to ensure
that one of those things, uh,
the, the most beneficial, whether it's
like the most beneficial, innovative, uh,
technology arises or do you,
you know,
err on the side of caution at all costs
and make sure that no one becomes a
victim of some emerging idea that
hasn't been vetted out yet? The,
we have a monopoly. They ere strongly in
the side of the precautionary principle.
So the, the, uh, regulators
are in an impossible position.
They have no way of evaluating all the
new stuff that, that comes online. Uh,
they don't,
they just don't have the resources.
So they have to do it in consultation
with the dominant industries who
invariably lean them towards, uh, you
know, don't allow this innovation through.
What if a disaster happens and regulators
are blamed for disasters and they
don't get credit for through all
the innovations that come, I'm
through.
But on the flip side,
aren't the people that are
coming up with these innovations,
wouldn't they try to influence them to
any regulatory body to let them slide
through because he's be
extremely profitable and wouldn't
they say, hey, you know,
this is all safe when maybe in
fact it hasn't. And how them,
there've been a bunch of
different medications that
have been released onto the
mark of it turned out like I remember,
um,
fen phen you remember that show people?
Uh, I remember this girl, she was about,
she was a pretty girl, but she was like,
man, I'm 30 pounds plus overweight.
And then one time I saw her and it
wasn't that long. It was, you know,
a few months later and all of a sudden
she's as skinny little bombshell. Yeah.
I like,
what the fuck is going
on? I'm like, what'd you do? Oh,
I'm on phen phen six months later,
heart problems, all these health
issues. She balloons up again.
But I guess I would on Finfin
too. Yes, it was. It wasn't easy,
but we should confront the fact like
our minds always go to this bad story.
And so we see the thalidomide
baby right from the 60s,
but we don't see the tens
of thousands of people,
hundreds of thousands and some
estimate even more than that,
that have died as the result of medical
innovations that are available, uh,
often in other countries and are already
approved that are not approved say in
the United States. Right.
Uh, so we don't need to,
you and I are not going to agree on a
balancing act and impose it on the world,
but we should recognize
that there's a cycle,
that it starts out being protective and
then it becomes over protective and then
it prevents and quashes innovation.
And when it's a monopoly,
it never innovate.
It never stops writing new rules.
And once it's controlled
by dominant interests, uh,
new people that don't have $1 billion
or 10 years to wait to get their drugs
through the process. And that is the, the
conservative estimate. 10 years. Yeah,
10 years.
Um,
so all sorts of new players innovating
and interesting spaces, like for instance,
in stem cells, uh, are
not able to, uh, compete.
So we don't get the
innovations that they have.
So there should be some regulation.
There should be something and it
shouldn't just be the market decides.
It shouldn't just be,
you know,
we'll let when people start dying and
people stop using it and then, you know,
now we know you can't. It can't be that,
right? I mean, the more time goes by,
the more I'm impressed with the power
of the market to, to regulate itself.
But in terms of medical things, I mean,
the people will become victims. I mean,
the market will regulate itself, but is,
are you, are you comfortable making that,
that distinction?
I think right now we're victims of
being denied the innovations that are
available that will let her held up or
preventing innovators from discovering
new things. Um, and you know, if you,
you know,
the same reason you put out a product
that isn't poison and you put effort into
your, um, podcasts at the
beginning to assure people,
I want to build a relationship with you,
and if you don't like it,
I'm going to give you your money back.
That's, that's a kind of regulation.
Like you're incentivized
to provide a good service.
If you put something out to kill somebody,
you're in a,
you're in a lot of trouble.
And I think people underestimate the
power of that kind of market force to
incentivize people to not poison
their patients. I agree with you.
But then even with all
the regulation in place,
you still have this
doctor Oz type situation.
You still have someone who's profiting
off of something that doesn't do Jack
Shit and is on television calling
it a miracle. Yeah. You know,
so I've been waiting for Doctor Oz to
go down and I, I'd be, I'd be curious,
which came first was it
was, uh, a journalist, uh,
exposing him and then,
uh,
governments came in and snapped him
down. I don't know what happened. I mean,
our idea is always that
it's doctors, it's A. Dot. It was actually
a medical student that chased it down.
There was a whole article about it
that was on, um, here, I'll pull it up.
Medical student.
So that, that, if that's true,
that's an example of a market
regulation that occurred.
Right. But how many people got
fleeced before that happened?
Meet the medical student who wants to
bring down Doctor Oz. This is the guy, um,
who,
uh,
his name is Benjamin Maser
and Benjamin Maser is a,
the student that saw,
I guess he was watching all these
different claims and he's like,
this is all horse shit. So
he, um, he chased it down.
Yeah. And Doctor Oz. I mean, he's a good
example of the point I'm trying to make.
I mean,
he's in a regulatory structure.
He's completely ensconced and what
he was doing wasn't stopped. It took,
uh, someone, you know,
coming from the ground up and analyzing
and himself probably a competitor and
exposing them as a fraud. I don't
know if it's hurt his career. Um,
but I'm sure people are reacting
against him. This is a good thing.
So we're describing, uh, the essence
of a market regulation right here.
I has the, has anyone from the
government come in and find Doctor Oz?
Has he been imprisoned?
Well, I know he was brought in front
of Congress. Aha. Yeah, it was a,
it was a big story. It was all
over the news, but he was, uh, uh,
on that, uh, what's that show? Um, the new
HBO show, the gentleman with the glasses,
John Oliver, John Oliver
did a whole piece on, uh,
on Doctor Oz and Dr Oz being brought in
front of Congress and Doctor Oz saying
one thing on his television show and then
saying completely contradictory there.
Dr Oz grilled and Congress had
missed admits weight loss products.
He touts don't pass scientific muster.
So we're, we're looking at, I mean,
we're looking at examples
of market regulation. Uh,
I'm not even going to take a hard
stance that we don't need any, uh,
regulations by, you know,
a central authority.
I'm maybe going to take
a hard stance on that.
I'm asking people to look at the power
of these kinds of things to regulate
itself. And the problem with, uh,
just accumulating thousands and thousands
of rules that prevent anyone from
trying something new.
And that's the situation we're in.
Yeah. I mean, I'm not a big
government guy. I'm not a
fan of big fan of government,
but it's just the devil's
advocate position I think
has to be sort of addressed
in these sort of scenarios because I
think there is the potential for fuckery.
And it's like how do you protect citizens
from things that they're not entirely
educated in?
What laws do you establish that
protect people from someone?
Victimizing someone with some sort of
an unproven product. Like, you know,
bad luck, job medicine that
leaves people crippled. There's,
there's that out there.
Yeah.
How do you deal with that and this
seasteading world and how do you keep,
you know,
how do you keep order?
Well,
it's the same way.
It's the same reason I don't put
out a book with no words in it.
And you don't put out a podcast
with just a bunch of Farts,
right? Uh, yeah. I mean, we,
we don't have monopoly
control over what we do.
There's other authors competing
to get you to read their books.
There's other podcasters competing to get
me to listen to them and I listened to
you instead.
Uh,
it's not about standing is not about
here's the list of rules we're going to
impose on the ocean.
It's confronting human nature and
there's always potential for fuckery.
People do shitty things.
And the way to solve that problem is
not to just take some of those shitty
people and give them absolute
power over everybody else.
And then they promised to make
everyone behave better. Uh,
I think governments will evolve and
innovations will occur if there's
decentralized power among multiple people
who can only profit and be selfish by
finding ways to serve
and please each other.
And that includes producing
regulations by which we behave.
That's fascinating.
So what you're essentially doing is
you're providing a method for new
civilizations to innovate. You're
not proposing any sort of guidelines.
You're not proposing any sort of
a new structure for government,
new structure for finances.
What you're doing is you,
you are sort of opening up the door and
allowing a wide variety of people to
come through and allow the
best ideas to float to the top.
Yeah. Seasteading is not about seizing
power from your political opponents.
It's about seeding power to your
political opponents to try their ideas
elsewhere, to see if they can create
something that will surprise you.
And you can laugh at the fiascos if
you want. Uh, but the more experiments,
the more likely we are to
discover solutions. And that's,
that's the truth of politics.
You know,
society is more complex
than this microphone.
I can't design this microphone.
Uh,
but I think I can design society through
my political opinions and the only tool
I have to do that is for.
So that forces me to fight over who's
going to control the government,
to force other people who disagree
with me to do what I want.
I don't think anyone
knows how to run society.
I think the solutions to humanity's
deepest challenges are discovered,
uh, and they're discovered by lots
of people trying lots of crazy ideas.
Well, I think one of the big issues in
society is what I call the quantity of
variables is that when you have
a very small group of people,
the variables are not that large.
And you can handle 20 people.
If we had a relationship with um,
19 other folks and we were all
living together on a, you know,
a large patch of land that had a good
amount of natural resources where that no
one had to worry about starving and death.
Why someone else lived high on the hog.
If everyone was even with the distribution
of natural resources and wouldn't be
that hard,
they wouldn't be a lot of conflict.
The real conflict comes when you have a
quantity of variables when you have 350
million people and then you
have things like immigration,
you have things like the stock market,
you know,
the things like do you know weird things
that go down in terms of loans and
terms of credit cards and there's so many
variables that that's when it becomes
incredibly difficult to manage a society
when no one person can be aware of all
the variables.
The quantity of variables gets
outside of the realm of comprehension.
Yes.
And everything that works out well for
us is outside the realm of comprehension.
I, I could not possibly make this table
or that water bottle or that computer.
You can make this table. I know the
dude made it. It's not that hard. Okay.
Well I wouldn't know where to get the
wood. I wouldn't know how to make it.
So there's no varnish. This is raw. That's
why it's called coffee stains. Yeah.
You could, uh, you could figure this
out, but I know what you're saying.
I wouldn't be able to make, you wouldn't
be able to make the microphone. Yes.
I think you make the table. I couldn't
make the microphone. You're a smart dude.
And uh, I appreciate how
the solutions, uh, emerge.
They're not, you know,
imposed by somebody.
They emerge from the kind of global
ecology of voluntary transactions that
produce the solutions. And the more
people you have trying different things,
the more peacefully they can
pick compete in the market,
the more likely these
solutions already would emerge.
And we need to update the governance,
the technology of governance,
just like other technologies.
And we can't do that through monopolies.
Is this something that you do full time?
I do it full time.
You're involved in seasteading fulltime?
Yes,
and it's the first real job I've ever had.
So I've always been a writer.
I tell stories.
I started out as a novelist.
I eventually became a science writer
once I was captivated by the seasteading
story.
Once I met the people I called
Aqua panners with all their ideas,
I realize this is the most important
story I could possibly tell. Uh, so I,
you know,
I've written the book,
it's going to come out next year
about seasteading, but I, I got,
I became such a sea Vangelis
I talked about it so much.
You have so many of those blue jobs.
See Evangelist.
Yeah. Aqua openers. Yeah. I'm a
professional bullshit artists.
The nerds in Silicon Valley need me
to sell their shit to the, to the,
to real people.
Um,
so they kind of brought me on to the
seasteading institute to talk about
seasteading. I, you know,
they were smart enough to see that I'm
driven by it and I'm passionate about it.
So, you know. And where does your money
come from, if you don't mind me asking?
Well now I'm working for
a nonprofit and I, I,
I'm a paid speaker and a nonprofit
is seasteading seasteading institute,
which was founded by Peter
Teal and Pantry Friedman.
So you get paid to evangelize,
see setting,
essentially I get paid to,
you know,
do lots of things with
regard to the nonprofit. Um,
and the money comes from donations
be money comes from donations.
So we have over a thousand donors or
a thousand people who have donated.
Uh, and we have hundreds of volunteers
that have gotten involved and we have
probably 85 ambassadors.
Uh,
W I'm getting so many
ambassador applications right
now. I can't keep up with it.
I want to be an ambassador.
Yeah, you, you should be,
you shouldn't serve on our board or
something. So imagine that kind of time.
Imagine a regular middle class person
who donates money to the seasteading
institute. I mean, people get infected
with this idea. They realize it.
Rather than arguing about my political,
my particular political problem,
I go deeper and realize it's the structure
itself that we just don't have the
innovations. We just don't have, um,
a numerous people experimenting
with new ideas. We got to,
we got to go deeper and, and, and hit
restart on multiple small governments,
micro countries on the sea,
and we'll discover solutions
we're not imagining now,
just like the United States discovered
solutions that were not in the
imaginations of monarchists
in previous centuries.
So explain to me how this works.
Like if someone says,
I think she's studying is a good idea.
Is there a Kickstarter page? Is there,
uh, do you have a paypal link? I mean,
how does someone donate to this
where it winds up being your income?
We have a donation page on the website.
Uh,
every time we send out our
newsletter to our fans,
we put a little donation link
there. We accept bitcoin. Um, it's,
it's pretty easy to donate
to the seasteading institute
if that's what you want
to do if you go to the website and are
inspired by it. And what is the website?
A seasteading.org and uh,
you know,
I strongly recommend checking out
the eight grade moral imperatives,
which is one of the problems
the seasteading institute
has had is that it's been
very technical and it's talking to,
you know,
aquatic engineers and there's legal
scholars talking about stuff and people go
and they're kind of overwhelmed by the
information and they don't know where to
start. So I've tried to popularize
the idea and create, you know,
eight little videos explaining just
the basic angles from which people are
approaching seasteading to solve global
challenges that people care about.
So the eight great moral imperatives you
have as a video on seasteading and what
is a, it's only a minute, right?
Each one is probably about
five minutes on average. Uh,
the introduction is a minute,
the introduction is a minute.
And then you can click on
any of the eight and it's,
and it's a list of things
like, do you, what do you see?
If you name me something you care about,
I can tell you about an aqua Opendoor
that's trying to solve that problem. Well,
let's click on the link. Jamie, go
to the eight great moral imperatives
and let's just play the introduction.
Um,
if you just Google the eight great
moral imperatives, it'll show up.
It's the first, uh, the first link,
but it's on seasteading.org and
there is a 53 second video that will,
uh, sort of, uh, introduced
this idea. Got It.
That that is the issue,
right? Moral imperatives.
That's the issue.
We got to get down past the divisive
political language and just talk about
human values that, you know,
conservatives, liberals,
Libertarians and anarchists and
everyone else shares for the most part.
Let's hear this.
When we listened to the sea,
we know what our moral imperatives are.
Feed the hungry, enrich
the poor here, the sick,
clean the atmosphere,
restore the oceans.
Live in balance with nature,
power, civilization sustainably.
Stop fighting.
I want to tell you about eight aqua up
honeymooners who plan to fulfill these
moral imperatives by building
floating cities on the seat.
Click on the issue you care about below
and maybe we can convince you to join
our growing seasteading community.
What is the timeline on,
on implementing this sort of a thing?
Like,
if you had to be realistic and you had
to make an estimate as to fuck how long
between now and when there really
is a floating civilization.
I've been, I've enjoyed. Um, well,
one way we can think about it is when
do we have to get one of these things
going? Uh, and I was very
impressed that the aqua partners,
I interviewed like six of them,
independently cited 20, 50, uh,
as a time where this is where we're
going to run out of fresh water. Uh,
this is when we're going
to run out of phosphate.
This is where we're going to reach peak
oil. You know, whatever people say.
And you know,
I'm not qualified to judge whether 20,
50 really is a deadline for humanity,
like a pinch point. And in several, uh,
key commodities,
humanity needs to survive.
But so let's say we have no choice but
to find solutions to global problems by
2050 and say,
I'm saying we can solve these problems
by engaging the power of the sea. Uh,
so that's, that's the
timeline. So I think,
I hope by 2020 we'll have a demonstration.
A see stead within the territorial
waters of a, of a host nation.
And if we can hire some local people,
create some blue jobs,
absorb a costal runoff, uh,
and turn that into algae,
that'll attract more ideas.
Um, I'm hoping maybe, you know,
you can imagine 20,
35 you have something on the deeper ocean.
People come up with a break water.
We have people contacting us right now
about you can create a solid break water
too to protect a city. Some nice. Yeah,
I'd have to be an incredibly cold
environment and apparently not.
Apparently you can get one
in the tropical oceans.
I'm not even going to
go into detail on this.
I'm using this as an example of like
qualified engineers that are coming to us
with ideas for how to,
how to do this on the Osha.
So you would use solar power to power
some sort of a freezing element that no,
apparently I, I'll have to point
you to his, his proposal. I mean,
apparently ice can sit for a very long
time if it's solid enough in even in
tropical borders, but, but
whatever, it's just one idea.
I like the Otec idea using the ocean as
a solar panel to replace fossil fuels.
Uh, a key idea to think
about, uh, ocean crops.
So something to think about.
70% of the world's fresh water is used
for agriculture between like a quarter
and a half of all land is used
for agriculture. Where we're,
we've depleted the top soil,
we're using up the freshwater
populations are going up,
we're facing a water crisis by 2050.
Then you think about the
fact that a algae crops, uh,
see farms require no fresh
water whatsoever. They
require no soil whatsoever.
Uh, and we haven't actually
reached pizza peak phosphate.
We've just taken it out of the soil
and dumped it into the oceans. Well,
what absorbs, uh, all these
nutrients that are the oceans? Well,
uh, algae farms, so we can park.
A lot of people are opposing that.
We park a algae farms around
the dead zones off the coast of,
of various cities in the world.
Absorb all that nutrient
and carbon pollution,
turn it into food and fuel over the
long haul. Um, that's just one problem.
Be Heavy metals though. I mean, when
you have you met artisan problem,
things along those lines, like you would,
you would be feeding that to people.
You can't extract that.
Well, you can't extract it.
Apparently there's people trying
things with muscles and various natural
organisms that remove these things from,
from uh, um, you know, there's the,
it's weird how many like bacteria and
small little creatures process this stuff
and people are talking about
we need to farm on that level.
We need to farm on these
tiny little levels.
So you would get some sort of organisms
that take out the heavy metals and then
the other organisms would eat the carbon
right and turn that into fuel. Well,
people are trying to create these,
um, you know, cyclical little systems.
They're already doing it on a small
scale, you know, involving muscles that,
that uh, um, you know, filter
feeders. W with this kind of fish,
with this kind of algae,
algae haven't undergone all the
artificial selection that makes wheat,
corn and soy so productive and
get allergies a lot healthier.
And a lot of people react and they say,
eh, algae, I don't want to eat that. Uh,
but most people don't know that algae is
already in most of the foods we eat. It.
It's, it's a fertilizer that
nourishes the land crops we use.
It's in toothpaste, it's in beer,
it's an ice cream. You know,
Carrageenan and Aguilar,
and I don't even know how to pronounce
all these aspects of then seaweed as well.
The seaweed is, is huge. Um, and it's
very healthy and it's very healthy.
It has a, it's probably the
healthiest plant in the world.
It has all the amino acids,
depending on the species.
A has a lot of fiber. You know, fish
don't synthesize their own Omega threes.
They get it by eating algae. Um, and
when you consider that, you know,
corn was this tiny little ugly
thing that no one wanted to eat.
Wheat is this, if you showed
someone a wheat stalk, they'd say,
I don't want to eat that. Uh, but you
just a few generations of artists,
official selection, you can create
all this marvelous stuff. We'd, uh,
we can do the same thing with,
uh,
with algae that we're already using
in our foods. And, uh, you know,
the bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation helped, uh,
Ricardo Radulovich, the founder of the Sea
Gordon's project. He's big on creating,
he wants to create a
seaweed farms on the sea.
He mixed a seaweed flower
with wheat flour, uh,
sending it to the developing world.
It does a lot for malnutrition
among those people.
There's so many ways you
can use the healthier plants
at the sea to feed people.
Uh, and, and you don't need
to use fresh water. Uh,
so a lot of people say agriculture needs
to become aquaculture and we can give,
you know,
Kansas back to the songbirds.
That's funny. Um, that's,
uh, it's a fascinating idea,
the idea of seasteading and um,
it's,
it's also fascinating to try to reverse
the process that we've already begun as
far as destroying the oceans as far as
the amount of pollution that were leaking
into the ocean,
as if that could actually benefit
some life forms in some sort of way.
And then we could sort of turn that
back around and get something out of it.
And that way.
Yeah. I mean [inaudible] has been the
keystone of the global carbon cycle,
you know, for three and a half billion
years, you know, it knows what it's doing.
And we've been working against the carbon
cycle and just like screwing up the
whole planet, we can turn that wheel
back around. If we base our food on,
on the ocean,
I've read something about dumping scrap
iron into the ocean to reaction Jane
oxygenate the Ocean because
dumping scrap iron to the ocean,
it would serve as a base for
algae to start growing on.
Yes.
So Patrick Takahashi and others propose
that for the OTEC supported plant ships
that you, you might have
to seed some iron. I mean,
there's ways this have to be tweaked
and when we get to this level of detail,
I just refer you to,
you know,
the experts who were talking about it
and we never know what's going to work.
You know, all these people are
thinking about these ideas,
experimenting with them on a small scale.
All this hopeless or hopeful stuff is
going on like what you just described.
And the idea is we need to open up this
frontier for people to experiment on.
We need to allow the ocean, uh, to,
to let civilization.
We need to base civilization on the ocean
because the fact that so much of it,
it's such a resource.
The ocean, uh, you know,
most of the oxygen comes from the ocean.
Life comes from the ocean.
Most of the oxygen comes from
the ocean as far as like,
like you mean seep seaweed
and things like that?
Yeah.
I mean,
seaweed forest make the world's rain
forests look like potted plants is what I
always say. When you consider like the
amount of carbon they store, the amount of
oxygen they produce. Yeah. Wow.
I know. I had no idea. I had
always assumed it was just forest.
No, it's mostly, uh, ocean crops
that, uh, keep the world in balance.
And the more, the more you, uh,
forest the oceans with say,
seaweed crops,
the more carbon to build their bio mass,
they have to pull this carbon
and nutrient out of the water,
which lowers the acidity of the ocean,
which is exactly what we need to do.
The more carbon you pull out
of the ocean, the more, uh, uh,
carbon the oceans pulls out of the air.
Um,
so you could reverse the whole carbon
problem by just creating a massive seaweed
farms on the ocean. And people have
calculated about how much he would need.
And it'd be the size of this
state of the size of this country.
And nobody really knows. But the fact is,
if we start ramping this up, uh, we could,
you know, soy, corn, wheat, it's
not that, not as healthy as like,
as like seaweed bread.
Isn't it amazing when you see issues
that pop up technological issues,
whether it's, uh, you know,
uh, pollution or what have you.
And then the,
these innovations come along to try to
deal with the solutions or to try to
create a solution for these issues.
And it seems like that's one of the
things that people do, like they seem,
it seems that people need to be in the
face of some sort of a problem to solve
in order to truly innovate.
And when you think of this Otec thing
and that this Otec thing happened during
the Carter administration, when the gas
problems were at the peak for that time,
changed the motor industry,
the automotive industry was forced to
make much more fuel efficient cars,
compact cars all came out of that,
you know, before the American cars,
these big V 10 pigs.
And then all of a sudden we had an issue.
And then innovation
springs from that issue.
And you look at all the
things that's going on today.
Like there's a young man who
invented some sort of, uh, uh,
at least a theoretical design to clean
up the plastic patch in the middle of the
Pacific garbage patch. Boyan Slat, I
think is his name. I don't know his name,
but a amazing idea that in a short amount
of time would be able to filter out
all that plastic and then perhaps
that plastic could be reused.
Perfect. Perfect idea. So yeah,
the seasteading institute gets proposals
about to clean up the great garbage
patch, right? And as a generalist who
tries to put this all together, uh,
someone described a,
an expert as someone who can describe to
you in great detail why something can't
be done. So I get humbled often
by experts that describe, well,
that's never going to work.
It's too hard to build a permanent
structure on the high seas.
And here's all the reasons why I look
at all this esoteric language I use.
That intimidates you went
to thinking I'm right.
And then a year and a half later,
I find out shell prelude is building
the fucking thing on the ocean.
So it turns out to Ken work.
Um,
so buoyance a slat is an example of this.
So he designed this system to
basically clean up the garbage patch,
the great [inaudible] pitch.
This is the system.
And he had a huge Ted talk that went
viral and went all over the world.
And what's so remarkable about him as the
only 19 years old, after a few months,
huge backlash,
uh,
people who knew better started criticizing
him and saying he doesn't know what
he's talking about and people fall for
these stupid ideas. And I'm like, well,
that's kind of embarrassing. I'm glad
I didn't like feature him too much.
I guess he is just a kid who doesn't
know what he's talking about.
So he rose to the challenge.
He got some funding,
he's out there on the water experimenting
and now the backlash has backlash.
Now people are saying, oh,
it is going to work. Uh,
we could ramp this up and clean the
great garbage patch. And guess what?
Nobody knows. We don't know. All we
know is he's proposed this thing.
It's attracting a lot of
brains to the problem.
People are inspired to get it done.
There's a backlash.
The backlash people were shown to be
demonstrated with an experiment on the
water that they were mistaken.
So he went out and did a small scale of
this and he was able to clean up some
stuff.
So if we scale this up a little work look,
cause another problem that
won't work is it, it, it,
it could even be a terrible idea.
But by galvanizing and being a
lightening rod for this problem,
it attracts new innovative minds to
update his solution and find the real
solution.
This is how the x prize works.
One of the biggest issues with human
civilization in regards to the ocean.
It's overfishing. It's a huge, huge issue.
What ideas have been
proposed that makes sense,
that you,
you're aware of that deal with that?
Well, I spoke about, uh,
Neil sims in the velella research
project a moment ago and I'm,
and I'm not doing justice to, to, to
what he's doing. So mobile fish cages,
uh, and it blurs the line between
fish farming and wild fish.
So fish farming gets a bad rap
because, you know, fish farms,
they're bolted to the coasts.
The fish swim in their own
poop that can't go anywhere.
They're not living normal lives.
Then you have to have, you know,
Bile Fallon's and all this stuff.
So he's just required us to completely
rethink what fish farming is.
And he takes it out in the deep
ocean where it's below the water.
You can't even see it.
The,
the cages float around in
Eddie's behind giant islands.
The fish float around
in there. Um, and there's, the
fish is healthy. It has no mercury.
It's higher Omega three content
than the wild version of that fish.
It's a totally new kind of fish,
a Kona [inaudible].
Why is it higher in Omega
three than the wild form fish?
Because apparently the fish live better,
uh, on the deep sea when they're like, uh,
fed, uh, by humans periodically,
like the wild, the wild.
I have no idea.
What are they feeding them?
They're feeding them a mix
of a fish meal and soy.
Uh, and then finishing it off
with fishmeal at the end. And, um,
uh, Sashimi guys, a guy named Wong in, um,
in Hawaii or declaring it,
you know, a great sashimi.
They've had taste tests with his
fish where the experts can't tell the
difference between farm
fish and wild fish.
So if this becomes profitable,
you're talking about creating huge
numbers of fish, uh, on the oceans.
And the problem is,
is that we treat the oceans like a giant
Commons and we're like hunter gatherers
out there exterminating them.
Um, we're not farming fish,
you know,
a hundred gatherers homosapiens left
Africa and just exterminated all the
megafauna on every continent. You know,
hunting fish is not the way to go.
We proved that with bisons mastodons,
even ducks. The way to, uh,
increase the biomass of the oceans is the
way we've increased the biomass of the
land,
which is to farm animals.
And Neil Sims is trying to do
this in a humane way. Well,
what was done with bisons
is lack of regulation.
What's been done with other animals,
game animals in this country is left
more dear in this country right now than
were there when Columbus landed. There's,
there's a way to manage wildlife.
There's a way to manage
certain amount of animals.
The problem is if everyone was hunting,
there would be no more wild animals.
The reality of wild animals is there's
not enough wild animals in relationship
to the amount of people that are
here is 350 million Americans.
They would require a lot of wild
animals if that's all we ate.
There's a way though to regulate.
And what the problem I think is least
as it's been understood as it's been
explained to me,
is that with fish you're dealing
with international waters.
So you're dealing with a bunch
of different nations. I mean,
they have an issue with the Japanese
crews that won't stop wailing.
They wail under the false pretense of
doing research, scientific research,
and then sell the whale carcasses. Having
these, there's these boats that the,
um,
the sea shepherds have a attacked and
have shown like time and time again.
Like these guys are fucking wailing.
They're not doing any experiments.
They're not doing scientific research.
But that's the loophole.
The loophole is that these Japanese boats
can still kill whales as long as it's
for quote unquote scientific research.
So they're just killing whales. Right.
You know, so the, the ocean,
that should not be a wild
west. It should be civilization.
It should be a part of, yeah.
Right. But if there's 7
billion people that want fish,
we have no choice but to farm fish.
Right.
It's like more than a billion people
get their main sustenance from fish and
that is going to go up. I mean, uh,
Lockheed Martin is
actually, um, funding, uh,
Neil Sims is, uh, experiments, uh,
as is like the copper industry and all
these different players are coming in
because they see the future of food is
in aquaculture. I mean, a lot of this is,
we get, we have no choice. It's
like we, you know, over the last,
what 50 years or century have exterminated
like 90% of the fish, the sessions,
it's like we either we turn that
around and we're going to have hunger.
Is there a way that they can somehow
another repopulate the wild populations of
these fish, like tuna have drastically
reduced. Did you see Jiro Dreams of Sushi?
No. Documentary.
Fascinating documentary. Um,
one of the sad aspects of it as he talked
about what it used to be like, it's,
it's about a guy who's been doing sushi
forever and it's all about his obsession
with creating the perfect dishes and
it really interested, well, maybe I did
see that. Is, is it set in? Um, it's,
it's just about this one Sushi chef.
I watched that with my wife.
We had mesmerized.
Yeah. Fascinating, right? Yeah.
The old man in Tokyo, um, in, uh,
in the subway station. He's
a very small place. Um,
I thought it was so my wife
wanted me to watch, I'm like,
I'm not Washington fucking guide,
make Sushi. He gives a shit.
And then more and more people told me,
it's not about that. You gotta see,
you gotta check it out.
And I watched it. Uh,
but the saddest thing was like showing
photos of the fish markets from the 1950s
and sixties,
and there was just fish everywhere.
And he was just talking about the
wide variety and the large numbers.
Enormous tuna were everywhere. It was just
insane. And now it's one 10th of that.
Yeah. And, and, and, um, Neil
sims refers to himself as a,
as a passionate environmentalist
and he went back and read about fish
populations in the world and you know,
he's a great fish kind of sword fish
lover. And when he talks about fish,
he salivates he's so excited about how
they behave and what they do and, and uh,
yeah,
you like,
you can hear the pain in his voice when
he talks about what the fish populations
were like in 1920 and we can't I long ago.
Yeah.
And we can't keep treating the oceans
like a toilet and like a thing where we
can just hunt as much fish as we want.
The fisheries have to be managed. Uh,
fish farms can help with that and we
have to repopulate the oceans with fish.
Yeah. Not just farm fish, but wild fish.
Like, that was what the question was,
was he,
do you know of any methods that are
being contemplated for repopulation
repopulating the wild fish?
The only way it would work is if it's
profitable to have lots of wild fish.
Um,
so true.
And then you would also have to stop
certain people from different nations.
You'd have to have some sort of an
agreement with a fisherman everywhere.
Yes. And, and people don't, don't realize
the, the oceans already, you know,
uh, there's like the United Nations
law of the seas, there's all these, um,
legal frameworks that already operate on
the ocean and allow people to interact
with each other and there's,
you know,
overlap in the jurisdictions and
it mostly gets worked out and it's,
Eh, the oceans is, you know,
sort of civilized and it's ready for
the next layer of legal evolution. Uh,
which I think is a stewards of the ocean,
I think.
I think we're ready for a kind of a new
evolution in market based evolution on
the water. I'm a marketplace
regulation on the water and,
and sovereign nations market based.
But the problem is that's how people
feed their families, make their profit,
run their business. They run their
business by pulling fish out of the water.
You would have to tell them
you're going to make less money.
Yeah. Pulling less fish. Right.
And that's hard to do. Yes.
And sims tells a story about
trying to work with, you know,
poor fishermen in the Cook Islands
and how there's just an incentive for
everyone to just take as much fish as
they can out of the comments. Um, and,
and so it's like if I don't grab the fish,
the other, the guys I'm competing with,
good.
Grab the fish and you can say yes,
but we'll need more fish for
next year if you killed them all.
Now we won't have any fish next season.
You know, so we have to have rules.
But then the complex reasons
why people behave, you know,
follow the rules and why they don't.
And the problem with it just being a
Commons where everyone's competing to get
fish out, everyone has an
incentive to cheat. So what,
what is the means by which you get people
to cooperate? To preserve the fish.
Longterm resources have to be managed
or they go away. Uh, the, the,
the present way we're dealing with
the oceans is obviously not working
right. And we would have to make
some sort of an agreement worldwide.
And that seems to me to be one of the
most difficult aspects of trying to fix
the whole po whole problem.
I think so, but it's, it's gotta be
worked out. Otherwise we'll run it a fish.
Yeah. And I hope they don't run
out of fish first and then say,
what do we do? You know, how do we fix
this? Right. I mean, even in areas where
they have brought back certain animals,
um,
to the animals that were
on the verge of extinction,
you still have to worry about poaching.
And I was still an issue all throughout
Africa with a lot of endangered species.
Obviously we know about this with
the rhino that even to this day,
even though all the knowledge that
everyone knows that rhinos are dying off,
there's still poaching.
Yeah.
And I was reading a recent explanation
lately about elephants in Africa and they
were contrasting Kenya with
a nation that's next to it.
And I forget what it is.
And you know, in, in one country,
the populations of elephants went up
and in another country the population of
elephants went down. And it was kind
of counterintuitive. Um, and you know,
the,
the place where the population
of elephants went down
was where there was just
like a government monopoly controlling,
which was the easily corrupted the
place where the populations went up.
And it would, it would, it was sort of
pseudo public but also privately owned.
So they'd sell a certain
amount of poaching where it
becomes somebody cash cow
to have elephants there. Cause you can't
just protect elephants and allow the, uh,
populations to grow as much as
you want. Right. So, I mean,
we can drill down and discuss
how regulations can evolve
to increase populations
of wild animals in a manageable way.
Um,
but you and I don't need to settle it now.
The fact is we need more solutions.
Well,
Africa is a very interesting analogy.
It's very interesting to compare what
they've done with wild animals in Africa
to what,
what needs to be done in the ocean.
Because there were many animals in Africa
that were on the verge of extinction
and now are quite,
quite common.
But they're quite common in these high
fence operations where they hunt them.
It's really weird,
like the populations of boomed on a lot
of animals that were almost in danger
just a few decades ago.
And now there's many of them,
like the highest numbers they've ever
recorded in Africa and some of these
species, but they're in these high fence
operations and that's a weird sort of a
contradictory situation when they've
become manageable, profitable,
they've, they've become a resource. Yeah.
It'd become a resource that you
can manage. And once that happens,
that's when their populations go up.
But then everyone's like, but no,
they're hunting them. Yes,
but there's more of them, but
they're killing them. Yes,
but there's more of them to kill. Right,
okay. It's not as a, it's a weird line.
And again, it's, it's the superstition
that I, as a cease dinner,
I'm always trying to get around.
The way you solve a problem is to create
a monopoly of Nice people who will make
everyone else be good. Uh, and we're,
we're talking about the same thing.
So some of the elephant populations
that are controlled by say a government
monopoly and nothing else,
those populations keep going down because
there's no one really incentivized to
protect against poaching. And you can,
if you, if your work for that monopoly,
you essentially have ownership over this.
So there's all sorts of reasons
to take payoffs and bribes.
It's also problem where the elephants,
um, uh, interact with people and,
and elephants are dangerous and elephants
knocked down trees. Um, you know,
elephants will,
will attack people.
And then in these other places in Africa
where I guess you described them as
high fence operations,
you make it so that a,
a stable elephant population is profitable
to the people who live there. Right?
So they say, all right,
we'll have like 5%.
We'll let people poach for a high number.
Well, they're not poaching. It's there.
That's actually illegal legal hunting.
I shouldn't say names. They pay like
$50,000 and they go kill an elephant.
It's kind of fucking crazy.
Yeah. But then the people in
charge of that are like, okay, now,
I mean there's either elephants or
hunted or elephants become overpopulated.
Yeah. Um, so there has to be a way
that these populations are managed.
It's not just a simple manner
of illegalizing the all
the killing of elephants.
And this is the hard thing for
people to get their minds around.
The hard thing for people to get their
minds around who love animals. Yes.
If you really truly want these
animals to have large populations,
you have to manage those populations.
And that's not something that
anybody wants to hear. Yeah.
And I love animals and my wife
is an animal fanatic. And,
and if we care about
animals continuing to exist,
we have to confront the fact that you
don't just protect them and allow their
populations to exponentially grow until
they starve or come in contact with
villages and kill people.
Well, that's a problem.
What we have in California with this,
this,
the government has outlawed in California
killing of a lot of predators that are
in large populations now.
Like most particularly mount mines,
there's a large population of mountain
lions in California now and subsequently
the deer population has dwindled.
They have dropped substantially.
And there's a place that I go to
called to hone ranch on one waterhole.
They have a trail camera that's photograph
16 different mountain lines. I mean,
that's fucking crazy.
That's 16 different animals that are
killing something virtually every day.
So every day,
16 different mean killing machines and
mount line is a machine and they kill
pigs, deer, elk, whatever
they can get ahold of.
And they're just decimating the deer
population decimating, you know, any, any,
any game animal they can get ahold
of and it's illegal to hunt them.
And it's not regulated. It's
not, it's not being managed,
it's not being managed correctly.
And one of the reason is
because public opinion,
public opinion based on
ignorance, they think, oh,
these asshole hunters want to
kill mountain lions. Well, no,
but you have to manage the
populations of all of these animals.
If we're going to be stewards
of the land you need,
they all need to be kept in check
and they all need to be monitored.
And it's not being done with these
specific predators just because of what I
believe is an ignorant public opinion.
And I,
and I agree with you and what people
are working so hard to do with elephants
and mountain lions,
it needs to be done with fish on
a massive scale and massive scale.
Bringing it back to what I care,
it should be a huge part of
what the government and the,
you know,
like it should be a huge
part of what we planned for.
And as far as like looking towards
the future, I mean, look at how,
what percentage of our diet is based
on seafood. It's gotta be enormous.
It's a huge percentage.
And we don't even realize that when we
eat some broccoli or we eat, you know,
a cow that, that the, uh, many
of the crops that, you know,
the cow ate or that came from the
bralette came from a allergy fertilizers,
you know, fuel feed and, um,
food, uh, are, are very largely
supported by ocean crops.
Do you live by the ocean? I,
yes, I do. You notion freak.
You're like one of those dudes out
there. I'm an ocean freak. Yes. This,
was this a part of your life always
or is this something that's sort of
developed? Um, I love the outdoors.
I was an eagle scout. Uh,
I love Forrest as well.
I do love being on the ocean.
I think I'd like to live on the ocean.
I think the first, you know,
if we get a good stead going,
I'd consider living there. Um,
but yeah, I'm having a backyard.
Sure. Ocean, I was just on
a boat, um, for, you know,
10 days or something a few weeks ago in
the Galapagos Islands and man sitting on
a boat and looking at it to see, you want
to talk about contemplation, relaxation,
you know, some nice breathing. It doesn't
take any discipline. It just happens.
You know,
the human mind I feel like is meant to
stare at fire and water and sky and then
it gets you to in mountains and
it gets you in a good place. Yeah.
Isn't that strange?
It's like these,
it's essentially artwork that's
designed by the universe. You know,
the thing that people love about artwork
is you get to look at something like
that, boot, that boot over there. You
look at it and go, wow, that's amazing.
That's really cool. If somebody built
that and that's so cool. Look at some,
it may not.
Well,
what a mountain is essentially
the most incredible artwork ever,
but it's completely natural. It's there
all the time and no one can own it.
And you can move, move around it,
look at it from different angles,
but it's essentially just like artwork
and gives you the same feeling that you
get when you look at a beautiful painting,
but magnified tenfold. A thousand fold.
I think so. I mean, we were staying
in a place in Colorado, my wife and I,
and I spent hours staring at a big man,
like it was a TV.
So that's deep in me. It was just, I,
I couldn't believe the comfort I got from
sitting on the porch and just looking
at this magnificent thing in
Colorado. Yeah. Um, so I don't know,
that's just a primal thing.
And I think the oceans men,
it affected me every time I'm on the
water and I'm just looking at the sky,
looking at the water, I feel like, wow,
I'm turning into a better person
just by sitting here. Yeah.
I have a friend who has a beach house and
we sometimes go to hang out with their
place. And, uh, when we,
uh, when we go there,
it's just amazing how
everything just Sorta, ah,
just sit there like looking at the water,
splashing up against the rocks
and everybody's just chilled out.
It's almost like it has some sort
of a tranquilizing effect on,
on everyone around it. He beach
communities are notoriously relaxed.
When was the last time you were in
a really hectic beach community?
They essentially don't exist and,
and you know,
there's always island paradises with like
people tell you it's just super mellow
people. Yeah. Hawaii.
I mean, Hawaii, look,
there's a lot of fights in Hawaii,
you know,
but you're also dealing
with Polynesian people,
some of the greatest warriors
throughout civilization.
So gangster that they got on
these little fucking canoes,
travel thousands of miles
across the ocean. I mean,
they're just very aggressive people.
Yeah.
But still pretty cool. I'm pretty
chilled out for the most part. Yeah.
I'm thinking about like little as like
the Seychelles islands and you know,
the people that live there.
I've never been to these places,
but I'm told by people who go there that
it's just like everyone is chill and
calm and it might be because they're
just looking at water all the time. Yeah.
And looking at the vastness of the ocean,
which sort of falls in the face
of any ideas that you have,
any delusions of grandeur or any, you
know, when you start looking at your life,
what's important,
what I need to do,
I need to get this done and
this deal needs to be made.
And then you look out the
ocean, like actually in the
greater spectrum, you know,
if you look at it in perspective, like,
come on, you're just a little blip,
little tiny little thing out there and
just maybe just enjoy it a little bit
more. Yeah. We, we, we evolved
from, uh, the ocean and the,
we'd have to complete the
cycle and get back to, uh,
get back to the ocean and become
a homo aquatic us or something.
Homo is on another one. You're
going to coin another. I just,
I just coined that just now.
Have you ever, uh, read the,
um, the theory about the aquatic ape?
Yes. I wrote a chapter about it in a book,
the aquatic ape hypothesis. What
do you think about that? Well,
explain it to people who don't
know what it means. Well,
it's this uncanny fact that human beings,
what makes us different from
other large apes and, uh,
other primates is that we share all
these qualities with marine mammals that
only occur among marine mammals.
And it includes a subcutaneous fat,
you know, a chimp stores. All
this fat between is Oregon's.
We have it just beneath our skin,
just like a manatee or something.
We have voluntary breath control.
We can,
we can jump in the water and swim
around. Uh, we have a diving reflex,
which otters have,
you know,
if you dive automatic shuts off your
nose and all this sort of stuff.
Chimp falls in the water drowns in
mere minutes, you know, uh, we're,
we're comfortable in water.
We're hairless.
Most mammals that are hairless
are our aquatic mammals.
Uh, and you start listing the more you
list all these qualities, people are like,
oh my God. We went through a stage
where we were like aquatic apes.
That's what made humans different.
Um, and it's one of the,
I think the aquatic ape hypothesis is
an excellent example of the difference
between a hypothesis and a theory.
Because what it has going for it is
tremendous explanatory power. It,
we don't have hard evidence
like a webbed hominid foot,
by the way. Um, 7% I think of human
beings are born with web toes.
That's one of the things people
don't know why, but yeah, 7%. Yeah.
See if that's still true.
It was true when I wrote my look it up.
Wow. So what I was researching this, you
know, whatever, six or eight years ago,
yeah, that was true. And I,
and I cited the reference web toes.
So then you think about, all right,
you take a uh, orangutan baby,
throw it into the water. It drowns
very fast. You take a human baby,
throw it into the water,
it knows how to hold its breath.
It waits till it comes to the surface and
then it naturally floats and kicks its
feet.
So there's all this weird like where
did we get all these qualities?
It's actually one in 2000
to 2,500 live births.
Well that's close enough.
Yeah. Well, you know, it's pretty small.
It's a one in 2001 and seven.
We're 7%.
What do you stickler for? Yeah, I'm
a stickler for facts. I'm crazy.
But it still is a, it's interesting
that it, I mean even that one in 2000,
it's fairly common.
I wonder if it's one in 2000.
That's more like a weird monopoly anomaly.
If it's something that's way more
common, like 1%, that could be something,
you know, atavistic like the appendix
something left and right. Right, right.
One of the other, um, things about the
Aquatic Cape theory that are compelling,
uh, some I should be an
oh, even large brains. Um,
the mammals with the largest brains are
mostly in relation to the rest of their
body are mostly aquatic animals.
Apparently dolphins, whales,
horcose also that we're,
um,
we're evolved to process and use,
you know,
fish fats really efficiently and
you're really, really well. I'm like,
why is that true?
All I know is the aquatic eight proponents
keep lining up all these things.
And in some cases, the only animals
that have these things in common are,
you know, aquatic mammals
and humans. So it, it,
it has to do with,
um,
the main ones are like hairlessness
and subcutaneous fat. What are the, uh,
country,
what are the arguments against this?
The arguments against it are we have
not found a single fossil that would,
that would support this,
this hypothesis.
So that's why it remains
officially a hypothesis.
Not An actual theory of the
fossils are really hard though.
That's the difference between,
you know,
one of the things about fossils is that
something has to happen in order to
create a fossil. For the most
part, most people that die,
your body is going to be absorbed by
the animals, the biology, by bacteria,
by rodents, scavengers, there'll
be nothing left. It has to,
something has to happen. You have to
be trapped in a mudslide. Volcano,
whatever it is, it's like covers you.
It's something that preserves you. Yeah.
I think the chapter aqua ape that I wrote
for that book is available online and
people can go check it out. I think I'm
going to have to, I'm gonna have to,
I can add that.
Now I've got to research this 7% thing.
Am I gonna have to update that?
You're going to have to update that.
It is a fascinating thing though.
The idea that the reason why people are
so different and why we like if you take
a baby and throw a baby in the water,
they immediately know the hold their
breath. It's a, it's instinctive. It's,
it is weird. And I'm like, why do we
have all these weird qualities? Yeah.
And then also the fat thing that if
you take a champ like a little baby,
chimps are hard,
hard little muscle.
Thanks baby babies are just floaty
little suckers. They're floaty. Yeah.
They're built with all this fat,
this fat. And then, you know,
if an orangutan gets really fat,
you,
you don't go up and squeeze fat on
the outside of its body. You know,
we store all this fat outside, uh,
our Oregon's, you know, in our,
in our, beneath our skin, this sort of
subcutaneous they call it. And that's a,
that's a quality of aquatic mammals.
It's,
it is weird that we have all
these qualities, but there's no,
there's just no hard evidence
is the thing. So it's,
and this massive attraction to
the, uh, to the ocean. I mean,
you don't see a bunch of baboons sitting
out there staring at the ocean and all
communities are founded, you
know, next to oceans. We,
we love the water.
Yeah. It's fascinating stuff. The Quad
Gate Theory and looking at it folks,
it's very interesting. Listen,
man, this is a great podcast.
I really enjoyed this very much as well.
It's a fascinating subject. Um, I think,
uh,
I think,
I think there's massive potential
for all of this and I think that, uh,
it's really cool that you were investing
so much time and so much energy and to
promoting these ideas and
a, I hope anybody listening
to this a explores further,
you know,
go to seasteading.org and check out the
website and see what they have to offer.
And a seasteading. Is it just seasteading
on um, on Twitter? What is the, uh,
the Twitter handle? I think it's
the CC sending institute. Yes.
That is a seasteading institute on
Twitter. Thanks man. I had a great time.
There's a lot of fun.
Yeah, I appreciate it.
Is there anything else you want to
direct people to or tell people about?
Go to the seasteading institute,
uh, checkout our, our,
our floating city survey.
Um,
let us know what you'd like to see on a
floating city. We have a donation page,
they're read up on stuff.
We are working on the floating city
project and we'd like you to check it out
and see if you think it's realistic
and if you'd like to move there.
Glorious. Thank you sir. Appreciate
it, man. It's a lot of file. Okay,
we are brought to you this week by
Squarespace. Thank you to our sponsors.
Go to squarespace.com use the code
word Joe and save 10% off your first
purchases. Thank you. Also to blue apron,
blue apron.
Uh,
an excellent way to get meals delivered
to your house that you can cook easily
with detailed instructions.
Uh,
go to blue apron.com forward slash Rogen
and get two free meals just for going
to blue apron.com. Forward
slash. Rogan. I use them.
I recommend them. Thanks also to
[inaudible] dot com go to o, n N.
I t use the Codeword Rogan and save
10% off any and all settlements.
Lots more podcasts coming this week.
Rich Vos is here on Wednesday.
Stefan Molyneux be here on Thursday.
Lots more stuff. Thanks everybody.
Take care of big kiss. Wow.